انا اليوم عندي برجر لذيذ مين اللي قال
لذيذ
انا جربته وكل اللي جوني من الشاب جربوه
يا حبيبي الشباب يجاملونك مطاعم ودراسات
على الاسواق برا فمعرف انا السعوديه بس
انه ستين في الميه من المطاعم المقاهي
اللي تفتحنا تكفل
هل النسبه قريبه في السعوديه 2023
ممكن نتجاوز 60% سؤالي في الاستراحات ما
اتاكد مجتمعين في استراحه جالسين ايش
رايكم نفتح
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح ناس تقول ان المطاعم في الرياض
وفي السعوديه كثيره والسوق متشبع لكن في
نفس الوقت الارقام تقول هذا الكلام فتلقى
في اليابان وسويسرا وغيرها من الدول عدد
المطاعم لعدد السكان اكثر باضعاف من
نسبتها في السعوديه فهذه الفرصه لفتح
مطاعم ومقاهي في السعوديه مع الوعود بنمو
هائل في عدد السكان يدعو اننا نشوف مطاعم
اكثر واكثر بان تكون اكثر تنوعا في كل شيء
الفئات الاصناف الاسعار الجوده وغيرها من
الاشياء اللي تخلي عندي المطاعم متنوعه
وثريه لاني ادري ان كثير من الشباب اليوم
يشوفون المطاعم والمقاهي فرصه لدخل مادي
وبناء شركات في هذا المجال كان ودي اسوي
حلقه عن هذا السوق واللي وين الفرص
الموجوده ووين الاخطاء اللي الناس تقع
فيها وتخلي هذه المشاريع تفشل هل ابني
العلامه التجاريه حقتي ولا اخذ حق امتيازك
على ما ناجحه هل الاستقاله من وظيفتي شرط
لنجاح مشروعي هل افتح مطعم على ارض الواقع
ولا افتح مطعم سحابي اسئله كثيره جدا
ومعلومات ثريه جدا في هذه الحلقه الممتعه
جدا مع ضيفي اللي خبرته في هذا القطاع
اكثر من 14 سنه ابو محمد عبد الرحمن
القحطاني
وطبعا لا يمكن تمر الحلقه وحديث عن
المطاعم دون الحديث عن اللاعب الجديد
ضخم في هذا السوق تطبيقات التوصيل وما
بقول اي شيء عنهم بخليه ضيفي واللي يقول
كل شيء
قبل ان نبدا
اذا كانت هذه الحلقه تهمك ففيه حلقات
متعدده في ثمانيه سواء في سؤال بزنس او
سقراط اللي تشرح قصص في هذا المجال سواء
عن تطبيقات التوصيل او مع علامات تجاريه
مميزه مثل برجرايزر وكودو في سؤال
في سقراط جميع الحلقات
نضعها في وصف هذه الحلقه اما الان لنبدا
انت مقيم في الخميس
والله ما اقدر اقول مقيمه الاولاد والاهل
والوالدين في الخميس
الاول في اول فرع في خميس مشيط في الحين
ففي واحد الخميس وواحد نعم هذا من
الابتلاء
[ضحك]
لكن وش اكثر واحد ايش الفرع الافضل اكثر
طلبا
لانه تجربه عميل مختلفه تماما
الرياض
مدري هذه نحطها في اللقاء
الرياض عميله متطلب
متطلع توقعات عاليه
انت بس تلبي هذه له يعطيك اللي في جيبه ما
يتردد كريم اذا اكرمت في الرياض مختلف
تجربتها مختلفه جدا قلت يمكن اهل الخميس
ما يحبون الحركات واحده من الثقافه هناك
ثقافه اصيله بزياده
ما يبغون الحنيد بشكل طبيعي ما يبغى انك
تشطح هنا في الرياض يحبوني يجربون ذلك انا
اقول عاصمه الترندات يمكن الرياض الان في
الوطن العربي
لذلك كل يوم انت تشوف حبه جديده شيء مختلف
من عواصم العالم جالس نستورد افضل ما
عندها يعني تجي مثلا البان كيك الكوري
تجده مرتب مبكج ومساوى يعني مغلف بشكل جيد
قدم للناس والناس ما شاء الله هنا موجود
بس احس الهبات انها مبرر للسوق
انك تفتح مطعم
تقفل ففجاه تطلع لك مشروبات كوريه ولا من
قريب
بس تذكر 2015 برجر بعدين فجاه يعني كل
فتره شاورما فحس الهبات تضر السوق فالناس
تحمس وتفتح مطعم بعدين يفشلون وهذه احدى
التحديات صراحه
القويه والخطيره في السوق اليوم فيها بات
لكن احيانا الهبات ما تصير هبه تر سلوك
مثل مثل بيتزا ما كنا ناكل بيتزا زمان
يعني ايامنا واحنا انا مدري والله كم عمار
الشباب هنا اكبر واحد هنا صحيح ايامنا
اللي كان ياكل بيتزا هو طبقه يعني ثريه
وطبقه يعني وضعها المادي جيد
ثم بعد ما دخلت كمبراند واكتسحوا السوق
وقدموا البيتزا باسعار منخفضه اصبح سلوك
كل اليوم
تقصدهم دومنت صح
يعني قبل المايسترو ما كان السعوديين ياكل
كان في بيتزا وكان في ظاهر
ثاني والله اني ناسي مثل
كان موجود لكن كانت الحبه بثمانيه واربعين
بخمسين ما احد يستطيع يعني خاصه نتكلم في
المحافظات
بس احنا مثلا في الجنوب يعني معلش
بدك ترد
ولا
هذا يلا
الرساله تعتبر رساله
معذره هذا بس على مثال
عشان تعرفون
ميزه حلوه
ابشر حقي يعني كل عمليات لازم تتم عن طريق
رساله ابن فهد والله شوف كثير مقترحات
نقدمها لبعض الجهات الحكوميه ارجو انهم
يستمعون لها يعني انا مثلا ماني مسؤول اني
في كل العمليات يعني انا مفوض عندي تفويض
للموظفين فالمفترض انه الموظف في بعض
الاشياء ما يرجع لي تجديد اقامه عامل
يعني عقد عمل منها القبيل هذه اشياء
موجوده عند مواد البشريه انا بعطيها
موافقه يكمل اجراء فما يحتاج يرجع لي
للاسف احنا اصبحنا يمكن شغلنا شاغل امس
نزلت تغريده انه ايش الوزارات اللي
نستخدمها
القطاع الحكومي
فاجات انه يمكن اكثر من 15 يوزر
استخدمها فهذه وحده ايضا التحديات انا ما
عندي مشكله مع كثره يعني هي مشكله انك
تدخلي يمين يشارك فيها بس انه اغلب الجهات
الحكوميه والخدمات مربوطه بيصاحب او
المفوض على الشركه والمؤسسه
ومربوطه بابشر
فتتورط انك لازم الكود بالله الكود
يمكن يبلغ عني فلازم اعطيه الكود
طيب كنا نقول البيتزا صح البيتزا صارت حبه
لما دخلوا
ثم يشتروا وانا اشوف انه يمكن من اهم
اللاعبين اللي غيروا في سلوك الناس لانه
دخل انتشر سعر منخفض
طعم جيد مقبول فغير في سلوك الناس انهم
يتوجهون للبيتزا فكان في طوابير ترى على
البيتزا زي ما هي موجوده الان مثلا على
الشاورما
فاصبح سلوك اصبح في ناس الان يوميا او
اسبوعيا لازم مرتين ثلاث ياكل بيتزا فما
كل هبه تروح
بعض الهبات تتحول الى سلوك طيب
انا اتوقع ان مشكله المطاعم انها من
المطاعم المقاهي ودينا دائما نتكلم عن
الثنتين هذا ان
هذا السوق يبدو سهل للناس كله
وش اقصد انه يعني الاخير كلنا نطبخ كل
البيوت تطبخ تقدر تفهم الفكره يعني بشيء
صعب
تاكل فتتوقع انك تقدر يعني ممكن انك
ذكرتها في البيت طعم مقارب
فجاه انه يقول لك انا اقدر اسوي المطعم
فكل شوي احد يفتح مطعم كل الناس تتوقع ان
فتحت مقهى ولا فتحت مطعم انها سهله وكل ما
يفتح مقهى ولا مطعم جديد تلقى يعني كثير
منها تلقين في طوابيل طويله يتصور كيف
يعني هنا في حولنا مطعم اسمه بوفيه
ويبيع شكشوك يعني ما هو يبيع شيء ابداع
يعني شكشوكه وبيض ومدري ايش وكذا الابداع
فيها السعر غالي ههه
بس الفكره انه اكل عادي يعني اكل اللي انت
تشوفه في اي مكان فتتوقع انك تقدر تسويه
كبده وزي كذا وانك بتدخل فكل الناس صارت
تسوي مطاعم هل فعلا بهذه السهوله دخول
الناس انهم اي احد في السعوديه يقدر يفتح
مطعم وبينجح انا اسمي المطاعم صناعه
المطاعم يجب ان تعطى من الاهتمام مثل ما
تعطى اي صناعه اخرى
الصناعه كصناعه بمعناها الحرفي او الصناعه
مستشفيات
قنوات هي صناعه لازم تاخذ حقها من اي
دراسه من اي تجهيز من
الالمام بكل اطراف الصناعه هو هذا الشيء
لانه يقولون كثره المساس تبلد الاحساس فكل
يوم هو يروح للمطعم يتوقع انه هذا هو
المطعم ادخل اشتري استلم طلب امشي نهايه
الشهر معي 200 300 ارباحنا 500% 700% هذا
الكلام غير صحيح البته ولو كان كذا
لكنا الحمد لله ما اقول الحمد لله الله
يعوضهم لكن اثبات للكلام اللي نقوله شوف
نتائج الشركات الغذائيه اليوم في سوق
المال انهيار يعني في الارباح سواء في
هرفي او في
ناس شغالين بالملي ترى يعني يدخل منظومات
هذه يرى الحوكمه العاليه يرى المشتريات
والمخزون والانتاج والمبيعات والتسويق يرى
كل القصه الكامله هذه فيجد ان هذا في
الاخير
97% نزول في الارباح السنه هذه فاذا نقص
خطر لازم يثبتون للشباب سوالف الاستراحات
ما تاكل عيش
مجتمعين في الاستراحه جالسين ايش رايكم
نفتح طبعا هذا موجود الى اليوم موجود
للاسف مع كل التحذير اللي نقوله
نفتح يلا انت والله فلان انت تقدر تسوي
قهوه كويسه يلا نفتح كم مراسل المال 100
الف راح جمعهم
450 متر كانوا يقولون بنبيع كذا كوب وجدوا
ما يبيعون ولا ولا شيء وحتى لو حصل انه
الموضوع في البدايه مشى معهم فانت ما انت
فاتح عشان تحبها وترند انت فاتح عشان
تستمر عشان تصنع لك لاولادك اللي بعده
تجاره اليوم اللي يمر عليك انت ما تبني
فيه شيء للمستقبل هذا انهيار فما اذا ما
كونت مشروع جيد دخل جيد استقرار انت جالس
تلعب
فسؤالي في الاستراحات هذه دخلت الناس في
الحيطه زي ما يقولون فالمفترض انها تؤخذ
بكل جوانبها والدخول بالشكل الصحيح او لا
يعني مقهى
راح اخذها من خطوه جمل ابد بيعطوني
المحصول هذا تاخذه من اي محل ثاني او حتى
من عندهم تلقى الموردين يجيبوا لك اياه
كاسات جيبها من الصين ولا حتى من السعوديه
ايش تعمل
وتقدر تحسبها يعني
مكلف يمكن
حديد مراعي يعني المساله ما فيها ذاك
الابداع اللي انت تخليني اتخيل انه صعب
اني علي اني افتح مقهى فعلا اقدر احسبها
ربحان واقدر اسوي ماني احسن من غيري يعني
او ما هم احسن مني يعني في ناس سوي كذا
ترى نجحوا
كذا لكن كم نسبتهم
هنا هنا الاشكاليه احنا اليوم لما نتكلم
نتكلم على سوق كامل فلما اتكلم فلما تقصد
السكان يعني اتكلم على قطاع مثلا نتكلم
على الرياض كامله مثلا فاذا مجموعه
اجتمعوا وسووا نفس الطريقه هذي ونجحوا ترى
في عشرين ثلاثين عملوا نفس الطريقه وفشلوا
مشكلتنا انه ما يظهر على السطح الا
التجارب الناجحه تعال ابحث عن التجارب
الفاشله وانا اقول للناس تبغى تستفيد من
السوق لا تروح للناجح الناجح اصلا ما تقدر
تدخل عليه طوابير عنده وكذا يعني ما تقدر
تشوف تفاصيل العمل اللي خلاه ينجح روح
للفاشن اجلس معاه حيعطيك كل حاجه حيقول لك
انتبه من كذا وانتبه من كذا انا اقول
للناس التفتوا البدر بجماله ترى له وجه
اخر مظلم
التفتوا للوجه المظلم وادرسوه بشكل جيد
ستجدون ان الوضع بالفعل ليس بالتفاعل اللي
بعض الناس ياخذونه ببساطه هل السوق فيه
خير نعم في خير كبير جدا لا زال السوق فيه
خير لكن اصبح اصعب من اول وهذه انا يعني
لي فلسفه كذا بسيطه في مساله السوق النار
هذه وحده من التحديات نسوق مره باربع
مراحل مرحله اولى نفتح الباب ويجونك الناس
وهذا اللي لازالوا الناس تتوقعونه الى
الان
المرحله الثانيه ما يكفي فتح الباب لازم
تشغل بشكل جيد ليه لانه يصبح عندك ترافيك
عالي يعني زحمه تشغل بشكل جيد الشيء
الثالث مع كثره الناس انت تختفي فلازم
تسوق
تظهر لهم في محركات البحث في السناب في كل
مكان الشيء الرابع لليوم نحن فيه واللي
لازم انتبه له
انه حتى لو سوقت كثير زيك يسوق والمنتج
الكوكيز اللي عندك موجود عند عشرات غيرك
ومن نفس المورد يمكن بس يغيرون البكج يعني
فقط اليوم لازم في مرحله اخيره بدينا فيها
هذه البحث والتطوير لا لازم انت تجيب شيء
ما احد سببك يعني سبب فيه لازم تجيب شيء
تستطيع اذا سوى وقته الناس يعني يشتاقون
يجربونها ليه لان ما موجود الا عندك هذه
اربع مراحل لما تشرحها للناس وتوعيهم فيها
يعرف ان الموضوع لا مو لعب انه لازم يؤخذ
الامر بحقه حتى تستطيع او
في خيارات اخرى ممكن نمر عليها بعدين ايش
المشكله
ان اللي تقول ان هذه اربع مراحل مر فيها
السوق
ودي اختلف معك
اني احس ان احنا المرحله الاولى اللي انت
قلتها افتح الباب يجونك
قبلها حتى
يعني ما وصلنا للبحث التطوير ولا يعني
يعني لا يزال يعني انت لو تجي ما ادري في
الرياض فتره طويله ولا لا يعني بعطيك ابسط
الاشياء اللي تسعديني
محل فول في الرياض ممتاز
يعني ما تقدر تقف رياض كلها يعني تلقى يا
دوب تقول هذا يمشي حالها فيعني بعطيك
اشياء بسيطه يعني حتى لو تبغى تروح للرز
واللحم وش في مطعم سوى حركه لانك تامين
اوكي لا يعني صدق والله تلقى فيه رومانسيه
كلهم عاديين يعني في حركات يمين ويسار
يعني مثلا تلقى واحد بس كلها ابداعات
بسيطه يعني
هذا هو مساله الابداع في كل المطاعم فلا
نزال يعني احس مره
متاخرين جدا عن وجود الاشياء الاساسيه من
شكل المطاعم الاساسيه اللي ما فيها ابداع
باقي في الاكل الاساسي عند السعوديه طيب
هو طبعا لكن ههه يمكن جزئيا ايوه عشان بس
عشان ما نخرج من هنا متخاصمين
هو في في امرين انا قلت مرحله البحث
والتطوير اليوم احنا تونا بعدين فيها اوكي
ولذلك في بعض الشركات
تحولت في شركات مطاعم تحولت قال انا ماني
الان شركه مطاعم انا اليوم تسويق وبحث
وتطوير ويقول الموظفين كذا مدري مسموح ذكر
الاسماء مثلا
ويقول يقول انا شركه تسويق وبحث وتطوير
المطاعم والبريشن هذه اسم مستقل انتو هنا
في الاداره العامه لازم نفكر بعد الطريقه
فلما تدخل عندهم ما تشوف الممارسات اللي
موجوده في المطاعم العاديه تدخل ترى تشوف
بيئه مختلفه تدخل تشوف مثلا انه قسم
التسويق يمكن اكبر قسم عنده ويهتم فيه
بشكل كبير قسم البحث والتطوير عند ناس
يعني يلفون السوق ليل نهار لذلك انا تابع
بعد موظفين مصعب حتى اشوف وش الجديد في
السوق مثلا
كل يوم رايحين مثلا مطعم رايحين يعني الى
درجه انه يقول انا عندي فريق هذا شخصيا
اشوف وش الجديد في السوق يقول انا ما
ابتكر شيء في السوق انا اشوف وش الجديد في
السوق المبتكر اللي بدا يلقى قبول ثم ابدا
انا من خلال الاله القويه اللي امريكا
انطلق فيها وانتشر ففي شركات اليوم شغاله
عن البحث والتطوير ما هي كثير صراحه يمكن
اقل من اصعب اليد الواحده لكن موجود احنا
بدينا المرحله هذه طيب نرجع لمساله الحين
قبل المرحله الاولى
اختلف معاك لانه طبعا لكل واحد معياره
وهذا معيار بشري يختلف من شخص الى شخص ابي
اتكلم عن عيار الخاص انا مثلا اطلع
خلينا نشوف خلنا نقول مثلا دبي اليوم
الخيارات الموجوده في الرياض في المطاعم
يمكن تضاهي الموجود في دبي اذا كانت دبي
هي تعتبر خلينا نقول ايقونه الغذاء او
الترفيه او المطاعم في الخليج موجوده
اليوم في الرياض بعض المطاعم اللي تنافس
اقوى الاسماء هناك
ما ودي والله اسوق نفسي لكن انا
الاماراتيين يجون الرياض على طول ينزلوننا
كتامي ويقولون تعال افتح عندنا من دبي
يقول هذا ما موجود عندنا في دبي وقس عليها
الكثير اللي هم افضل مني واحسن مني قد
يكون يعني شو اقول لك
قوه المنافسه الموجوده في الرياض تخلق انه
لا والله هذا الشيء مكرر هذا الشيء موجود
هذا الشيء لانه ما يمدي احد يبتكر لو فيه
عشرين ثلاثين قلدوا الابتكار هذا وذاب في
السوق فيمكن هذا اللي انت مثلا تشعر به
لكن سوق في الرياض انا اراهن عليه انه بدا
مرحله جديده وانه قادم بشكل افضل اذا ما
حصل يعني في السوق لخبط الفتره القادمه مش
اللي بيحسب
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
في مشكلتين بشكل عام وحده داخليه وحده
عالميه العالميه موضوع التضخم الي صاير
والقوه الشرعيه واحجام الناس من القبيل
داخليه انه التوسع في السوق اكبر من مساله
خلني اقول لك زياده الناس او طلب الناس
فانت لو مريت الرياض قبل خمس سنوات أمريت
الرياضه اليوم وجدت انه يمكن اربعه اضعاف
في السوق قبل خمس سنوات بينما البشر في
الرياض يمكن مره ونص يمكن او مره وربع
فاكيد يعني اللي بيفتح بياخذ من حصه اللي
فاتح خطا يعني فهذا اللي سبب الضعف السوق
حاليا
لذلك انا يعني نرجع ونقول مساله المطاعم
مساله يحتاج لها الى دراسه وتاني وعدم
خلنا نقول الخروج عن الطوق الموجود لانه
بالفعل في طحن في السوق فيه اشكالات كبيره
سنه عن سنه في سوق المطاعم المقاهي
عشان نكون محددين الاموال اللي تمت عن
طريق نقاط البيع في المقاهي المطاعم هذا
شرحتها اكثر من مره يا جماعه احنا نتكلم
عن نقاط البيع نقاط البيع هذا السلوك عند
الناس تغير اليوم انا لي يمكن خمس ايام ما
شليت في جيبي كاش بس اليوم وصلت المطار
اخذت كاش في جيم اللي شغله معينه وصلت
صرفتها وقفلت الموضوع والان يمكن باقي مئه
ريال انا صار يمكن 600 ريال
فنقاط البيع قطعا ترتفع ليس معنى ان زاد
استهلاك الناس ابدا هو تحول الناس من
الكاش الى نقاط البيع اعطيك مثال عندنا في
مطاعمنا يعني عده مطاعم من فرع وفرعينه
وتسعه فروع وفرعين وغيرها ما كانت نقاط
البيع ولا تجي يمكن 20%
ترى الكلام هذا قبل كورونا اربع سنوات خمس
سنوات
من كورونا وجاي عشرين في الميه فقط اللي
تتم عن طريق البيع باقي اتكلم انا عن
تجربتي الشخصيه اللي هي في المطاعم
الشعبيه لكن قد يكون غيري اكثر بس بشكل
عام بس يعني المعيار اوكي
كورونا يعني قوه التغيير يعني انا لو اقول
للواي واحد تبغى تشوف قوه تغيير سلوك
الناس شوف اللي صار في كورونا
لذلك هل يمكن تغيير سلوك الناس هذا طبعا
يمكن سؤال جدلي اخر ممكن القوه تغير
السلوك قوه التغيير خلت حتى سائق التاكسي
معه atm او نقطه
اللي كان اخر واحد كنت متوقع انه ياخذ
فاللي صار انه تحولوا الناس من نقاط البيع
الكاش الى نقاط البيع لذلك تعال شوف نقاط
البيع من بعد كورونا الى الان مستقره رقم
واحد واحيانا تلقاها تنزل في بعض الاحيان
هذا واحد الامر الثاني هات نقاط البيع
وخلنا نشتغل تحليل الارقام بالضبط
وزع نقاط البيع هذه على عدد الاسر في
السعوديه
وشوف كم يطلع نصيب كل اسره في الاسبوع
شراء من المطاعم ما ادري والله كان الرقم
يعني يمكن يحسب لاحقا ونزلها في ثمانيه
حساب ثمانيه لكن اذكر انك يعني كان رقم
بسيط 60 ريال 50 ريال 70 ريال لكل اسره
اخذت التعداد السكاني عدد الاسر وجبت
العمليات مجموعها في الاسبوع قسمت سبعه
على عدد الاسر وانتهى الرقم بسيط لا يذكر
بس هلا هذا الرقم مشمول
لتطبيقات التوصيل
تطبيقات التوصيل حصتها من او لو وزعتها
على الاسر الرقم مو كبير
بس اليوم برضو يعني انت تقول انه في تشبع
في السوق من ناحيه المطاعم المقاهي انا
اقول فيه منافسه كبيره جالسه تسحب البساط
من تحت بعض
والمنافسه منطقيه بس قصدي حتى المنافسه
يعني لما تطالع ارقام مثلا ارقام اليابان
تقع عندهم 16
الف مطعم لكل
لكل مليون نسمه
وفي سويسرا برضو رقم سته الاف لكل مليون
نسمه في الرياء في السعوديه
يعني تماما عن السوق العالمي في كثره
المطاعم وحتى مثالك في دبي يعني اعتقد انه
يعني يمكن في مطاعم شعبيه تنقص وجودها في
الامارات في صديق لي يعني معاذ فكان يقول
ابغى بخاري في دبي جلس خمسين راح المطعم
بعيد خمسين دقيقه ومطعم سيء جدا فيبدو ان
المطاعم الشعبيه هي اللي تنقش بس ما يمديك
برضه تقارن
الكم والكيف الموجود برضه فالعدد حتى قليل
جدا يعني يفترض انه باقي نوصل الى اضعاف
في شيء في الدول العالم مختلف عن السعوديه
ابحث في دول العالم تجد انه اغلب المطاعم
هذه يعني تجاره عائليه تلقى الاب
واولاده او بناته هم اللي شغالين في هذا
المكان فلذلك يكون في عدد كبير فلو باع
مبيعات بسيطه طلع نهايه الشهر مصروفه
واولاده اللهم لك الحمد
هنا لا هنا بزنس بزنس هنا تجاره تجاره
تجاره العائليه غير موجوده انا شفتوا
عائله واحده بس في الدمام ماخذين كذا لوبي
حق فندق تجربه جميله جدا انا ناسي والله
الاسميه فجيت بالفعل الاب
وزوجته وبناته هم اللي يديرون هذا المكان
وشغالين عليه هذا انا اتوقع كذا هذا
تحليلي هذا فارق التشبيه ما بين هنا وهنا
لكن لما نروح مثلا نسافر برا ما نشوف يعني
مثلا
خلنا نقول باريس
قبل خمس سنوات واليوم مطعم فاتح جديد
عندهم
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
وانا من اخر رياضه شمال الرياض امر على
500 مطعم طيب وقف عند مين مين اللي بيجيب
يجذبني هنا يبقى انه الموضوع هذا صعوبته
كيف انت يعني تستعود على عملك مع هذا الكم
الكبير اللي جالسين نشوفه ولذلك يعني سؤال
اخر حتى لو عندك مطعمكم المفضل وهذا ممكن
اسالك اياه يعني الاختبار مطعمكم مفضل في
البرجر
اخر مره
[موسيقى]
اطلب من نكهه تانيه فيعني على طول اول ما
اشتهي عندي مطاعم جيده لا تطلب
سوينا كذا مسح بسيط من شريحه من الناس وين
مطعمك المفضل قال كذا اخر مره اكلت فيه
قبل شهرين طيب من شهرين الان ما اكلت لا
اكلت وين اكلت قال والله جربت براند اعلان
كذا طيب اذا كان هذا عميلك اللي له ولا
عالي ويحبك وما اكلمك الا قبل شهرين من
شهرين الى الان ما ارجع لك
هذا تحدي كبير هذا هذا خطوره السوق اللي
احنا نتكلم فيه كيف انه يعني استحواذك على
العميل ثم استمراره معكم اذكر اول ما فتحت
نكت امير خميس مشيط كان عندي عملاء في
الشهر تقريبا اربعين مره
في الشهر الواحد
بعد ما بدات المنافسه وصارت يعني كثير من
البراندات بدات في الحديد في المنطقه
الجنوبيه عندنا في الجنوب كان الحنيذ في
المطابخ
بس بالانفار ما كان منتشر بشكل كبير فبدت
تنتشر وبداوا حتى اصحاب المطابخ ينزلون
مثلا بالانفار
لا بدينا نفقد عمينا
لمساله التسويق عشان تاخذ عميل جديد
عشان يجيك واحد ما يجده عند غيرك فيستمر
معك بشكل دائم زي ما يصير معك الان مثلا
فهنا اشكاليه وتحدي السوق يعني حتى لو قلت
انه ما في عدد كبير اليوم سلوك العميل ما
جالس يرجع لي
هذه اشكاليه كبيره يواجهون اصحاب المطاعم
طبعا انا ما ادري يعني هل ممكن يقيس
الرياض وسلوك اثر الرياض باللي يصير مثلا
في باريس باللي يصير في
سويسرا او اليابان هذا امر اخر يعني معروض
للنقاش لازم يعاد النظر فيه لانه احيانا
قد يعني هذا يعطيك مثلا معلومه مضلله او
مثليدنج زي ما يقولون انه احنا ناخذ
معايير عالميه هل معايير عالميه تنطبق
علينا مشكلتنا انه ما في مثلا جهه فلتر
هذا الامر لانه يعني ممكن ننتقل نقطه اخرى
انه العميل اليوم سابقا كان ديموغرافي
يعني في استهداف العملاء عمره جلسه مستوى
دخله هذا انتهى اليوم ليه
مثال بسيط اليوم اللي يشوفون التيك توك
كله كل الناس هذا سلوك الشايب يشوفه
والطفل يشوفه
اذا ما اصبح مساله ديموغرافيه التصنيف
موجوده الان
فاصبح لي اولا طبعا لما كنا من هو عملك
ابدا اصف عميل بهذا الاوصاف عمره سنه دخله
عليها مصباح العميل لا شيء اخر اللي هو
سلوك العميل انا والله استهدف اجيب منتج
استهدف فيه السلوك فمثلا اجيب منتج ليوم
الجمعه
غدا الجمعه نعرف ان السلوك عند اغلب
السعوديه من اللي ياكل غداء الجمعه
لا تقدر تقول والله الشيبان ولا الشباب
ولا البنات
فاستهداف السلوك هذا هو اللي يقول لازم
اذا اخذنا معلومه من الخارج نتاكد هل
السلوك اللي موجود في الخارج
بس يعني على نقطه المطعم كنت مفضل يعني
كل فتره باستمرار بس انه منطقي انه ما
تاكل في مطعم
عندي مطاعم مفضله في اشياء معينه ما بعيده
بس المقهى المفضل تلقاني استمر عليه كل
اسبوع وممكن في ناس وغير اني ابغى اجرب
يعني فهذه الخيارات هي اللي تخليني اني ما
ارجع لك باستمرار انه مساله السوق اليوم
ليس بالسهوله اللي تصورها الناس
سهل لكن لما تدخل في التفاصيل هذه وتعرف
المعلومات هذه تعرف انه السوق لا ما هو بس
انك افتح باب او احنا قبل مرحله فتح الباب
لا لا سوق اعمق او
اشمل من مساله هذا السلوك فقط بس يعني على
فتحه الباب يعني احنا اليوم في مجمع فنقدر
نشوف يعني طبعا ما يعني يغيب عني اذا هو
سوى اعلانات وترويج ولا لا عشان هي الناس
تحب تروح المجمعات وتمشي وزي كذا
تجرب يعني فجاه اول ما يفتح مطعم تفقي
عليه الرجل عاليه يعني خصوصا في البدايه
فاذا اثبت نفسه استمرت اذا ما اثبت نفسه
الناس مشت هذي فالسلوك فتح الباب ترى سهل
لا يزعل يعني لا لا انا طبعا لما اتكلم عن
مراحل ما الغي المرحله السابقه يعني انت
لازم تفتح الباب وتشغلك كويس وتسوق وتبحث
التطوير بس انك اول ما تفتح الباب في زبي
مو دايما
انا بقول مثلا شفت مطعم
فطور او شيء زي كذا يعني ما ادري لمحت
اللوحه
على طريق الامير تركي الاول
هذا المطعم والله انه يقف
بقفل قطعا يعني لا يمكننا ينجح ليش ليش
شفت الشعار شفت طريقه يعني
كل الاشياء اللي من بعيد تقول لي انه واضح
انه ما يدلها
وبعدين بيجي بعدها بسنه ويقفل
وش يقول بينزل لك في التويتر يقول لك لا
تفتح مطعم انا فتحت في افضل مكان
الاول عند البوليفارد
مع الدائري مطعم فطور يعني بيعطيك كل
الاشياء اللي فعلا او مقهى بس يعني هو
انتو ايش قدمت فانا احس ان الناس
تجيب بس اول ما تقدم المنتج جيد يعني في
السوق لا يزال يبغى بس مشكلتنا مع انه لما
تقدم منتج رديء اذا قدمت منتج ممتاز او
جيد وما فوق بالنسبه تجيك يعني فكره خروج
الناس اللي انت قلت انه اغلب الناس تخرج
لانهم استراحات
[ضحك]
افضل مكان
تقدم منتج تتوقع انه كويس
وتسوي مثلا ديكور قد يكون مثلا جميل او
جيد ثم تقفل
هذه وحده من الخيارات الموجوده في السوق
اللي نواعي فيها الناس ترى ممكن تقفل حتى
لانه في امر اخر احنا ما ندري كان
والارزاق من الله سبحانه وتعالى وما نبغى
ندخل في الامر هذا لانها فيها شيء من
الغيبيات اللي اذا انطبقت على شخص ما اقدر
اطبقها على الباقي هذا لا وضعها الخاص
اللي ما يمكن سحب نفس
المثال على الجميع فهذا اللي فتح في هذا
المكان ثم فشل
تجد عنده امور هو كان يتوقع انها صحيحه هي
خاطئه لذلك في كثير من الاشياء اللي
نعملها في في المطاعم لازم نتجرد من
احكامنا الشخصيه ايش تقصد يعني انا اليوم
عندي برجر لذيذ من اللي قال
انا جربته وكل اللي جوني من الشاب جربوه
يا حبيبي الشباب يجاملونك
في طريقه يتصلون في بعض الزملاء يستشرون
اقول خذ البرجر حقك لفه في قصدير عادي وخذ
المنافس اللي انت تبغى تنافسه ولفه في نفس
القصدير وقدم الاثنين للاخوياك اللي حولك
شوف النتائج
ترى كثير تصير صادمه بعضهم ما شاء الله
يكون الافضل بس كثير تصير صادمه بعدين
اجربها عندي ما انزل منتج الا شوف وين
المنافس وانزله للموظفين انزله اصدقاء
انزل العملاء اللي جوني من برا وكل جرب
اذا لم يجمع الجميع يعني خلنا نقول نسبه
90% انا اللي عندي افضل ما انزلها ابدا
لا زلت انا من المدرسه الكلاسيكيه اللي
اقول ان المنتج راس الحربه ولو كثير من
الزملاء يعني عارضني في هذا الامر بس انا
اقول في الاخير انا مطعم
ويمكن اني اقول كلام هذا واجد العذر لهم
اني انا في المجال الشعبي والمجال الشعبي
هذا مطروح في السعوديه بشكل كبير وثائقه
الناس فيه عاليه جدا فلازم اتاكد بالفعل
اني انا مرضي الناس وش المدرسه الثانيه
المدرسه الثانيه اللي هو يقدم شيء اساسا
ليس من الثقافه المحليه يقول مثلا خلنا
نقول مثلا في المناقيش
القحطاني عنده فلسفه هو عنده مناقيش
معجنات يقول قد المنتج اعلى متوسط السوق
بسعر اقل من متوسط السوق وابشر بالخير
طبعا هذه قاعده جميله جدا وبالفعل خارج
الشعبي ممتازه وتجيب نتيجه ولا تتبعتها
وجدت بالفعل انه في براندات جابت نتائج
مذهله بسبب هذه القاعده افضل من اعلم
متوسط السوق
وسعر اقل متوسط السؤال المشكله اليوم تعال
يا نادر مين الحكم المتوسط السوق
هنا يبقى جهد الانسان وقبل توفيق الله
سبحانه وتعالى له في الحصول على هذا
المعيار اني بالفعل انا افضل متوسط السوق
واقل متوسط السوق
يعني تكلم مثلا انا جيت الرياض نزلت فريق
تقريبا من خمسه اشخاص يلفون كل مطاعم
الشعبي في الرياض عشان يذوبوا طبعا اثق في
ضايقتهم او اثنين منهم على الاقل يلفون
الرياض ويجيبوا لي الاسعار والتقييم
الاسعار والتقييم وجدت اني ممكن كنت بلحم
في جدار ترى لي خبره يمكن لما فتحت في
الرياض 12 سنه
فكنت ممكن افتح واقفل وما انجح لاني ما
عرفت وين متوسطات السوق او الناس
المنافسين مش اللي اكتشفته اكتشفت انه انا
نازل بسعر قد يكون عالي جدا ما يناسب
الناس ليه كنت فارد اما في المنتج الحمد
لله كان جيد يعني باجماع الجميع وبالتجربه
زي ما ذكرناها قبل شوي لكن كنت واثق بعد
الله سبحانه وتعالى في منتجي بزياده فقلت
بشطح وجدت اني بشطح بدخل مرحله
للشعبي مثل بعض المطاعم لا لا مختلفه مو
انا فما اقدر اسال اسعاره اللي بيشتري من
عندي
حتى لو كنت مثلا انا اجود منها شوي في
الاكل لكن لا في في عوامل اخرى لازم
ارائها فعدنا التسعير عدنا صناعه او تصنيع
المنتجات وطلعنا باسعار ارجو ان شاء الله
انها تكون مناسبه الى اليوم الحمد لله
طيبه الحمد لله ولله الحمد
[موسيقى]
انا ولا تزوجت ولا انخطفت في
المكسيك
كوكب اليابان
شفتوني في المكسيك والصين واليابان وروسيا
شفنا التاريخ وثقافات واشياء مره جميله
واكيد لاحظته انه في مواسم في السنه تكون
فيها الحياه غير تشوف فيها عادات مره
رهيبه
فهذه سنه في رمضان حاخذكم في رحله هذه
الرحله حتكون لسبعه دول العربيه او يمكن
ثمانيه حنشوف فيها اجواء رمضان ونجلس مع
الناس ونسمع قصصهم وحكاويهم واساطيرهم هلا
ايوه
نجلس على سفرهم وناكل من اكلهم فتابعوني
في رحله مع انس اسكندر على قناه ثمانيه
[موسيقى]
طيب على الاستراحات اللي احس ان هذه نقطه
مره مهمه فاودي نركز عليها شوي
لانه اغلب
احسن الناس اللي فاهمه واللي عندهم
الشركات والملاء الماليه هذول ما هم
بيتفرجون حلقه عشان يقررون شيء لكن عندنا
مثلا زي خالد الله يحفظه فهذا كنا قاعدين
يعني في استراحه قبل كم يوم هذا صديق
يقول انا اشرب
شاهي كل يوم
كل يوم لازم ثلاثه اربعه ويروح
قال خليني باخذ
الامتياز بفتح واحد ودامني انا اروح كل
يوم فانا باشرف عليه يعني وظيفه الاساسيه
وبياخذ الامتياز وبيفتح وكل اللي فتحه زيه
يدخلون فلوس عاليه
ليش لا كان في نقاش
لو كنت في النقاش
ليش لا
حقيقه اليوم السوق يمر بحاله لا يقين خلني
اعطيك مثال
جاني عبد العزيز القحطاني صاحب شيء عزيز
قريب هنا وقال استشيرك المكان هذا قلت له
لا تفتح وشاهي وكان بيجيك احد وكذا الكلام
يمكن بعد كورونا مباشره
ما استمعني وفتح واليوم ما شاء الله تبارك
الله يكلمني امس يقول ابغى افتح الفرع
الثاني باخذ مكان ثاني
فتعلم درس ليش لا وين المشكله
اليوم انا انا من الناس اللي مقدس التجربه
بشكل كبير جدا اذا تستطيع تجرب بعد ما
تستعين بالله وتاخذ كل ما تستطيع من عوامل
النجاح جرب
[موسيقى]
ما تستطيع ابدا لا
يستطيع يجرب يعني
لها يعني هي تعريف واسع لكن خلني اعطيه
معيار واحد اذا حطيت ال500 الف و300 الف
هذي واحترقت عليك تماما قفلت ما ارجع لك
ولا ريال منها ما تاثر على حياتك ومعيشتك
واسرتك ووضعك يعني المعيشه اذا هذا
المعيار موجود عندك طبعا المعيار المادي
يتكلم عنه فجرب وش عوامل للنجاح انت قلت
اذا برضو قدرت انك تضبط عوامل النجاح
[موسيقى]
طبعا بعد توفيق الله سبحانه وتعالى
اختيار السوق المناسب التوقيت المناسب
السلوك المناسب التسعير المناسب
الموقع المناسب اتوقع هذه اهم عوالم عوامل
عوامل نجاح اللي ممكن تكون موجوده
طيب بس على هذه الفكره اللي ليش لا يعني
مفترض انها حق الاستراحات ما عندك مشكله
كل واحد يفتح لي اي شيء لا لا انا ما عندي
مشكله في اصحاب الاستراحات يسوي احنا
مشاريعنا طلعت عندنا شركات اليوم
استثماريه ويمكن يعني تدير صفقات
بالملايين
يعني احنا كنا على شاطئ وطلعنا بفكره
وبدينا فيها لكن كان عندنا جاهزين لو
خسرنا ما ياثر على البزنس حقنا ما عندنا
مشكله وين الاشكاليه في في موضوع
الاستراحات اغلبهم توه متوظف ما عندنا دخل
وظيفته راح طلع لها قرض تجمعوا كلهم بجروب
دخلوا احترقت السالفه زي ما يقولون جالس
يسدد خمس سنوات ست سنوات قدام قصد اخر
زواجه عطله على المشاريعه عن استثمارات
الاخرى شراء عقار ايا كان هذا هو بس
الخلاف تستطيع ليش لا
يعني توكل على الله
طيب وين يعني في مطاعم ودراسات على
الاسواق برا فما اعرف انا السعوديه بس انه
ستين في المئه من المطاعم المقاهي اللي
تفتح تفشل
في السعوديه يعني عارف انك تشتغل في السوق
14 سنه مستشار كثير فهل هذه النسبه قريبه
استوديو ولا بعيده
2022 23 لا 2023
ممكن نتجاوز 60% من مطاعم الجديده اللي
فتحت
ابرز الاسباب اللي تخلي هذه المطاعم تقفل
او المقاهي قبل الاسباب خلني اعطيك ظاهره
نحاول نفتح عيون الناس ترى اللي ينجح
يصارخ
اللي يموت يموت بصمت ما احد يدري عنه هذه
ترى مهمه اللي بيراقب يراقب جيده السؤال
ايش الاسباب ابرز اسباب الفشل اللي تخلي
هذه المطاعم المقاهي تفشل شو الاشياء اللي
ما ينتبهوا لها يتوقعونها سهله في الاخير
يفشل لي هذه الاسباب غالبا ما يطبق الشيء
اللي ذكرناه قبل شوي يعني ما يهتم
بالتفاصيل اللي نتكلم عنها يعني اليوم
المطاعم
انا حسبت العمليات التشغيليه الموجوده
عندنا مثلا في الشعبي تتجاوز سنويا اكثر
من اربعه مليون عمليه
تشغيليه ترى الرقم هذا متحفظ وعديته
يقولون طبعا لما اقول عمليه تشغيليه
استلام منتج تسليم منتج تخزين بيع فاتوره
طباعه تنزيل الطلب رفع الطلب هذه كلها
تعتبر عمليات تشغيليه عدم الاهتمام بكل
التفاصيل التشغيليه والماليه والتسويقيه
والبحث والتطوير هي من اسباب الفشل اليوم
اذا انت تدخل زيك زي الناس نصيحه لا تدخل
لذا تدخل في السوق اعطينا اكثر من قاعده
يعني حاول تجيب شيء مختلف تبحث بشكل جيد
طور منتج بشكل جيد تاكد ان الناس يبغونه
تاكد ان في سلوك يتوافق مع هذا المنتج
بعد ما تقوم بالبحث الكامل تبدا في مرحله
تصميم المونتاج واختيار الخامات
بعدين تروح لمساله التكاليف وحسب التكاليف
والتسعير وهل سعرك هذا اللي بتقدم المنتج
هذا مناسب للفئه للسلوك اللي انت تستهدفه
ولا لا هذا اخيرا تبدا تروح تقول وين افتح
انا افتح هل افتح محل افتح يعني اسر منتجه
اذا اخترت المكان اللي يناسب الفئه والفئه
المستهدفه اللي هي سلوكها هذا تصل بسهوله
ويصلونك بسهوله هذه يمكن هي اغلب العوامل
اللي لو ما عملتها قد تفشل امر اخر وهذا
يرجع ايضا قلت ترى توفيق الله اولا واخيرا
ليس كل اسباب النجاح مطلوبه لاجل تنجح
ترى ممكن تسوي ثلاثه اربعه اسباب من اصل
سته وتنجح ليش قد تكون مثلا في سوق ما في
منافسه عاليه قد تكون جبت منتج جيد مع ما
اهتميت بالموقع لكن منتج جيد جاب الناس
عندك يعني
لذلك انا اقول لك لازم تقوم باغلب لانه ما
تدري وين السبب اللي بينجحك باغلب الاسباب
التي تستطيعها انه واحد اثنين منها قد
تكون هي سبب نجاحك بعد توفيق الله سبحانه
طيب
هل يتطلب التفرغ الكامل
لنجاح مشروعك
والله تعتمد على استراتيجيه الشخص
وخذنا نقول خطته لهذا البيزنس فبعضهم يقول
ابغى اجرب لا لا تتفرج جرب خذ راحتك افتح
يوم قفل يوم كيفك مادامك تجرب ما احد يقدر
يلومك
وهو ترى كان في مطاعم كذا بعدين اصبحت
مثلي اظن كان
في جده حق
البدايه لا لا يمكن اغلب الموضوع كان
عباره كان يقفل كان يفتح يوم واحد في
الاسبوع ترى
يوم واحد بس واليوم هذا الطوابير
يجربون الشباب حقهم طيب بقيه اسبوع ليش ما
تفتح
بس انه ما كان جالس يشتغل في وظيفه ثانيه
لانه فاضي لهذا اليوم يبدو ما اعرف والله
ايش ظروفهم لكن اقول اذا كنت لازم تجرب لا
تتفرق
بس ما تتوقع انه اذا وجالس يجرب انه
احتماليه الفشل عالي جدا
يعني
لا لا لانه الفشل ده انا مريت مراحل اكثر
من نجاح حلو ومراحل الفشل هذه لو كانت بشر
قبلت جبينه ايش الاشياء فيها
فتحت مطاعم كثير وقفلتها
يعني مثلا كان عندي مطعم
حبيبي هذا من احب البرندات اللي فتحتها في
حياتي للاسف كثفتها ولما قفلتها كان الاخ
اللي ماسك الاداره عندي يبكي يقول يا ابو
محمد تكفى لا نقفله يعني خلنا نستمر قلت
فهذي واحده من قرارات الفاشله اللي انا
عملتها في حياتي لاني وجدت بعد ما قفلت
انه ما استطعت ارجع ابني نفس البراند بنفس
القوه بنفس التجربه الجميله اللي كانت
حاولت يعني مش كانت فكرته طبعا هو مضغوط
لكن كان بنكهه جميله
اتكلم مثلا في الجنوب بمكان لطيف ديكور
جميل خدمه ممتازه جدا مكان يعني كان لائق
جدا والناس كانوا يحبونه
قفلته للطمع فتحت لك تاميه في نفس الوقت
واول ما فتحت هاميه كانت ترند وكان ما شاء
الله يعني مبيعات عاليه وجيده وكذا قلت
ليش مع انه ما كان عندي مشكله انه يستمر
هذاك
بس اقول لا
ركز هناك ما ادري والله هل كان اساسا الى
اليوم انا اقول لك صح او خطا لكن اتكلم من
هذا كان قرار ارى انه واحده من المحطات
الفشل اللي تعلمت فيها في الحياه بس يبدو
انك فشلت في انك بس قررت لمشروع ناجح انك
توقفه ايه بس المشروع الثاني
سر عليه بعدين الدروب وكذا وعطلت الموضوع
وكذا من هالقبيل فاذا واضح ان اي مشروب ان
شاء الله بينجح يعني في السوق
يعني انت فشلك انك بطلت من مشروع ناجح
اوكي تبغى يعني قصه فشل فشل
صدقيه طيب في شركه مؤخرا اسسناها كانت
تهتم بالمطابخ السحابيه
ودخلنا السوق وازعم انه يمكننا اول شركه
في السعوديه متخصصه في بناء البراندات
السحابيه
ودخلنا صراحه بقوه
وكانوا ناس يراقبونا بشكل جيد
وهذه نصيحه ثانيه لا تكون الاول في السوق
دائما
بعد ما بدينا كنا نتوقع السوق بشكل معين
بسلوك معين تفاجانا انه مختلف تماما
يعني كنا نتوقع مثلا انك يكون عندك وتنتشر
فيه في مطابخ سحابيه مستاجره زي بعض
الشركات اللي تاجر انه هذا يحقق لك ارباح
عاليه جدا ظهرت لنا مشاكل تشغيليه هذه
اشكاليه كبيره ظهرت لنا انه البنيه
التحتيه غير جاهزه عند هذه الشركات
ظهر لنا انه موضوع التوصيل من مطابخ هذه
للعملاء ما كان بالكفاءه العاليه طالما ان
العملاء يختلفون من حي الى حي فالبرجر
اللي تبيعه بشمال الرياض لا يمكن انك
تبيعه في شرق او غرب الرياض
قال لنا ايضا تكاليف ما خطرت على البال
يعني موضوع مطابخ السحابيه والتطبيقات
التوصيل تاكل تقريبا اكثر من 50% من
المبيعات
فهذه كلها ما كنا يعني متوقعينها
لا لا احنا الاول طبعا هذا النموذج لا في
ناس سابقينا فيه اللي
لا احنا شركه تملك برانداتها وتحط عندهم
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
يعني هذه واحده من محطات الفشل اللي عرفنا
فيها انه هذا السوق
في السعوديه لا زال الى الان يحتاج الى
اعاده نظر بشكل كبير وانه ما يمكن الى
اليوم انا في ما اعرف
شركه مهتمه ببرندات السحابيه حققت نجاح
عندنا تجربه اخرى لاحد الشركاء في جده
جالس يتدرب جالس يتعلم
والى حد ما وصل الى المصفوفه الصحيحه في
موضوع مطابخ السحابيه فهذه تجربه فاشله
انا نقول ما اقدر اقول لها الان فاشله
100% لانه احنا وقفنا النشاط ما اغلقنا
اوقفنا العيد مثلا ترتيب اتفاقنا ومن
هالقبيل لكن المرحله الماضيه كانت فيها
يعني تعثر بسبب ان كنا الاول ما كنا
فاهمين تعلمنا انا بالنسبه لي يمكن درس
كبير جدا درس كبير حتى على مستوى العلاقه
مع الشركاء مجلس الاداره اتخاذ القرارات
التوظيف الموردين المفاوضه فهو عالم مختلف
عن الشيء اللي انا كنت اعرفه فيه 12 13
المطاعم السحابيه هل
اذا عندي فكره اني اسوي مطعم ولا كوكيز
ولا يعني فكره جديده جالس اجربها هل اسهل
علي اني ادخل بالمطاعم السحابيه فاقلل فرص
الخساره فلو كانت خساره بتكون خساره اقل
اني ما ساجرت مكان ما سويت كلها له الليله
فهل هي مكان تجربه جيد خطوه اولى للتجربه
التجربه خطوه اي ممكن اي بس انه
مكلفه يعني انت اليوم تستاجر المساحه يمكن
اثنين في اثنين او اثنين في ثلاثه اثنين
في ثلاثه تقريبا
بثمانيه الاف شهريا
صح فيها معدات ما معدات وكذا لكن 8000
شهريه فهي مكانه تجربه لكن ما هو رخيص كما
يتوقع الناس
شهريا زائد ياخذ 25% من زائد نسب اخرى
ياخذها في التشغيل في التخزين اذا عندك
متخزن عنده غير التطبيقات التوصيل لانك
اذا انت سحابي معناها لازم تروح التطبيقات
التوصيل فهي اوكي مكان للتجربه لكن ليست
مكان للربح وجهه نظري الا في حاله واحده
انه اساس المطاعم شغال انت عندك مطاعم بره
السوق وشغال بشكل جيد ولكن تبغى تنتشر في
مناطق ما تبغى تفتح فيها فروع ثقيله فممكن
تدخل مطابخ هذه لفتره مؤقته تتاكد من قوه
الطلب هناك بعدين لازم تطلع الى مكانك
الخاص لانه مكانك الخاص او فر لك على جميع
المستويات
في المطاعم السحبيه على المدى البعيد
خساره كذا الى الان ما في شيء يبشر وهذا
الشيء موجود عندنا برا ولا
برا اولا نشات المطابخ السحابيه اساسا جت
من ظهر اوروبا تقريبا في البدايه لسبب ان
الاماكن المكتظه اللي فيها طلب عالي في
المطاعم الايجارات غاليه فصاحب العقار
ايجارها يعني عالي وصاحب المطعم ما يقدر
يستاجر فطلع بنموذج بين الاثنين ان انا
احول عقار هذا الى مطابخ صغيره واجيب
اصحاب المطاعم خذوا مساحات على قدكم احنا
هذا ما هو موجود عندنا الى اليوم في
الرياض يعني اليوم انت تبغى تاخذ مطبخ
سحابي خاص فيك اذا انت هناك تدفع مثلا
100,000 في اثنين في ثلاثه حتدفع 60 الف
يمكن في اربعين متر
في منطقه يسمونها نقطه ساخنه وتثبت
التوصيل بها عالي وتفتح بابك وتجيك
المندوبين اللي عندك خلاص انت في لوح
وجونك زي الان بعض الشركات اللي بدات
تنتشر في السوق ياخذ مكان واحد يحط خمس
براندات او ست براندات لوحه اماميه وخلاص
هذا مطبخ صحابي هذا النموذج الى اليوم
جالس يعني استطاع انه يصارع ما اقول لك
انه نجح 100% لكن خرج من عنق الزجاجه باقي
الان يحقق النجاح
فهذه هي الفرق بين مطابخابيه في السعوديه
وهناك طيب بالنسبه للسوق اذا برجع للسوق
يعني في نظرتين يعني في اليوم لما يشوفون
الناس الاخبار مثل اللي صار معي هرفيزر
كيف انخفاض المبيعات والارباح
فيقولون والله واضح ان السوق
بس نكتب الطالب برضه يعني انا يعني مذهل
بالنسبه لي
معك
فقديش فروعه تفتح باستمرار بعرف الكيلو
الواحد يعني تلقاه يمكن اربع فروع
[موسيقى]
سبعه
في الكيلو الواحد تلقى اربع فروع فيبدو ان
في طلب عالي جدا
في الجانب وفي جانب تشوف انه جسر يخسرون
فهل كيف نقدر نفهم السوق اولا اذا جينا
نقارن حتى تكون مقارنه عادله هذه الاسماء
الكبيره ما نقدر نقارن فيها ابدا اي لا
يختلف الوضع اليوم معك عشان يختار الموقع
عنده لغه عنده مصفوفه لازم يشتغل عليها
عشان يختار الموقع هذه المصفوفه يعني يمكن
تشترى بعشرات الالوف
طبعا واغلب الشركات الكبيره فانا ما اقدر
اقول للناس شوفوا هذا شغال وعنده زحمه هذا
يبدر الاسباب اللي ذكرناها والتفاصيل
بالشكل المطلوب بعد توفيق الله سبحانه
وتعالى يحصل على نتائج جيده هذا في قوه
علامه التجاريه ولاء العملاء اللي عنده
يعني هذه واحده من الاشكالات الموجوده
حاليا القياس على مثل هذه الظواهر
ومشكلتنا قلت لك ان اللي ينجح يصرخ
الناس يتوقعون يعني اليوم يا اخي والله
انا اجي مثلا اجمع سكه هنا زحمه اكيد مجمع
سكه زحمه بس اطلع وراها شوي تحت فوق وشوف
الناس ما عندها احد
فالزحمه اكيد انها زحمه
لانه اصبح يعني منطقه دستنيشن منطقه
الذهاب للناس
فهل السوق لا زال يحتاج انا اقول
السوق يحتاج الى الى الشيء النوعي متعطش
جدا الى الشيء النوعي وانا اضمن اي واحد
باذن الله بعد توفيق الله يدخل الرياض او
في السعوديه بشيء نوعي في المنطقه اللي هو
فيها انه يحقق نجاح باهر باذن الله وش
الاشياء اللي السوق متشبع منها وايش
الاشياء النوعيه اللي لا يزال فاضي فيها
شوف الارقام تقول انه البرجر شاورما
يعني يمكن هذه اكثر اثنين البيتزا الى حد
ما ومشكل البيتزا فيه لاعبين كبار يعني
شرسين
في اي دخول عليهم يعني قد يكون هناك
مقاومه عاليه من طرف المتحكمين في السوق
فيمكن هذه ثلاث قطاعات فيها تشبع واللي ما
في تشبع وفي فرصه انك تقدر تدخلها لكل
قطاع يعني اتكلم اليوم مثلا عن المضغوط
يعني هذه اكله شعبيه بعض المناطق جيتها في
السعوديه ما عندهم احد يعني وهذه يمكن شيء
اخر المحافظات فيها فرص كبيره جدا بالنجاح
باذن الله
فلما تقول تعال عطني براند مضغوط مميز جدا
في المدينه الفلانيه لتعداد سكانها قد يصل
الى 150 الف متين الف مثل من طرفها ما في
احد يعني
اظن رحت تبوك
وسالت ولفيت لفه بسيطه صراحه بس اني سالت
وين مطعم مضبوط كلهم يروحون يقولون المطعم
هذا هذا حاشي حاجه والله ما ادري
الان وشفت الزحمه عليه طيب غيرك قالوا ما
في طيب هذا معناها في فرصه ثانيه او في
فرصه في هذه المدينه انك تجيب مضغوط نوعي
وتتسح السوق وتحصل للاخير
فلسوق يفتقر الى الشيء النوعي
يعني في غير الثلاث اشياء اللي ذكرناها
هذه اخذتها في الرياض
بس اصعب الرياض حتى في الرياض بس اصعب متى
افتح في الرياض ما تفتح برا الرياض
وهل في فرق
نتكلم عن السلوك فلو اقول لك وجهه نظري
وين يعني اكثر منطقه فيها تركيز دخل عالي
وين ممكن تكون يعني دخلهم دائما عالي
انا اتوقع الخبر حكم موظفينا
لكن الخبر يعتبر من اضعف المدن في
المبيعات
يمكن الخميس مشيط اقوى منه مراحل هذه
ارقام انا شفتها حقيقه فلما اروح الخبره
والمعقوله يعني هذا الموظفين ارامكو
ودخلوهم عالي اجد ان الجماعه اصلا عندهم
سلوك مختلف بحكم طبعا يبدو الدراسه
والوظيفه وكذا اثرت عليهم انه عندهم سلوك
مختلف في مساله الانفاق
يهتمون بالادخار الانفاق عندهم بشكل مثلا
معين
الاجازات عندهم لها طقوس مثلا قد تكون
مثلا برا السعوديه او في اماكن مختلفه
لذلك هذا السلوك اثر على الاقتصاد في
المطاعم في مدينه الخبر لكن تروح مثلا وين
اقول لك محايل محايل عسير يعني بحكم
اسال الله يبارك لهم يعني بعض الزملاء
هناك فاتحين ومنتجهم متوسط او اعلى من
المتوسط ما شاء الله تبارك الله ارقام
عاليه ليه
سلوك الشعب فهو او الناس في محايل سلوك
استهلاكي عالي
هذا الامر يعني وين تفتح في الرياض او
خارج الرياض يرجع الى فئتك المستهدفه
سلوكها وين موجود
اليوم مثلا اتكلم في الشيء العادي شاورما
برجر شعبي يعني هذا العادي او المعروف
المحافظات افضل بكثير افضل من الرياض
لانها مثل مثل ملعب الحاره اذا دخل واحد
كذا شوي يعرف يلعب كلهم قام يصفقون
بينما في الرياض هذا مثل استخدم الملك فهد
اذا ما تدخل رونالدو ولا ميسي ما حد يصفق
لك زي ما يقولون ملعب المحترفين في الرياض
هل في فرق في الدخل جدا
اللي يدخل الرياض باحتراف عالي يحقق ارقام
مهوله يعني
ما بدنا نتكلم بعد ارقام يقول اداره تصدق
يعني حدث الناس بما يعقلون في ارقام عاليه
جدا في الرياض بس مو كلهم المحترفين صراحه
طيب في مقطع
لاحد اصحاب المقاهي طلع في روتانا ناس
قديم يعني يمكن سنه كان يقول انه يدخل في
الشاطئ من مئه الف ريال
روحوا له اذا ذاكرتي
ما مدى مصداقيه الارقام
اظن اخطاء من شده الفرح
لا يبدو لي حتى انا نزلت عليها تغريده
وسنابه وصار عليها حراك كبير وهدود يمكن
فوق اثنين مليون وحاجه مشاهدات التغريده
وهو بعدين يعني قال انه لا انا اقصده ما
اقصد بعض الشباب اللي يتواصلوا معه
ما في احد يعني يعني اليوم انا اقول اقوى
مقهى في الرياض في عدد العملاء والمبيعات
واستمر لفتره طويله هو نمط
فيها انا مقهى انس بن مالك
فيعني يقول انا وصلت الى عدد فواتير عالي
اتصل فيه اتصالهم يقول انا اراهن ما احد
وصل عدد الفواتير كما قاهي زيي
ما وصلت في هذاك الشهر الثمانيه الف اللي
يتكلم عنها يمكن ولا حتى
فهذا رقم طبعا غير صحيح هل هو يقصد مبيعات
فممكن في بعض المقاهي وتصل
لكن ارباح صعب جدا كم متوسط الارباح في
المقاهي نسبه
والله انا ما عندي مقهى عشان احكم عليه
واكون دقيق في الاجابه لكن
في عوامل كثير اتوقع انها تتراوح مثلا من
15 الى 18% الى 30%
هل ممكن اي مطعم او مقهى يربح مئه في
المئه
والله ابو تميم مالي معظم في احد في
العالم
[ضحك]
فيه احد في العالم او قاعده رياضيه تقول
ان في صافي ربح 100%
ما يمكن يعني انت بعت 100 ريال ربحت مئه
ريال
اذا تبيع منتج ليس خدمه يمكن خدمهها بعدها
شوي لكن كمنتج منتج كلفني مئه ريال اربح
فيه مئه ريال هذا معنى ربح 100% ترى وهذا
اشكال عند الناس الناس يعني يقولون لا
يعني هو يقصد انه كلف كريال وبعتب ريالين
اه اوكي تعال هنا هذي قصه ثانيه هذا ما هو
ما يسمى هذا يسمى يمكن اجمالي الارباح او
من الارباح حتى ما يسمى ارباح يعني في
محاسبيه فما في طبعا 100% هذا ينسى الواحد
لكن هل ممكن المنتج يكلف مثلا ريال وتبيعه
بريالين ايوه ممكن لكن هل الربح الريال
الثاني صافي ربح طبعا لا
يعني يعطيك مثال اليوم احنا مثلا ابي ارجع
مثلا خلنا نقول خلنا نقول برجر البرجر بس
يعني حبه البرجر بالتغليف حقها هذا يكلف
في الاسعار الطبيعيه لانه الموضوع يعتمد
على السعر نفسه الاسعار الطبيعيه في السوق
35%
طيب هذا 35% انت عارف انت كاليف التشغيل
اليوم وصلت الى اكثر من 40% عند بعض
المطاعم 40% من المبيعات يعني تبيع مئه
الف عندك اربعين الف هذه تكاليف تشغيل وقد
تكون اكثر
والسبب انه احنا اذا الموضوع بس منتج يا
حبيبي تعالوا خذوا خذوا المنتج يمكن بالسر
اللي تبغونه اليوم التكلفه الاغلب ليست
منتج يعني سابقا صراحه كان اغلى شيء اعلى
بنت التكلفه المباشره اليوم يمكن الثالث
او الرابع ارتكب مباشره هي التي تدخل في
المنتج بشكل مباشر فاذا بعت بمئه الف
حيكون تكلفتك 20,000 اذا بعت 200 الف
حتكون اربعين الف رقم ثابت نسبه ثابته
الغير مباشره اللي ما لها دخل في المنتج
لكن فيما يخدم المنتج ايجار كهرباء عماله
رسوم حكوميه هذه تكلفه غير مباشره اليوم
هذا ارتفعت بشكل كبير جدا
وحتى التكلفه المباشره من بعد كورونا الى
اليوم بعض المواد ارتفعت 300% طبعا هذا مو
كلامي هذا كلام يعني في لقاء ثمانيه في
سقراط مع عبد الرحمن مع عمر الجرايسي
الرئيس التنفيذي الامير حقه ماكدونالدز
كنت بعض المواد عندنا 300% ارتفعت هذه
كلها تؤثر على التكلفه المباشره تخيل
التكلفه مباشره ترتفع تكلفه غير مباشره
ترتفع ثم قدره شرائيه وقوه شرائيه تنخفض
يعني انت بين المطرقه والسندان الارباح
هذه غير موجوده
ماكدونالدز يقول انا كنت اربح قبل كورونا
10% حدودها يقول اليوم اربع خمسه في المئه
هذا اللي تقول انت في كل حاره في كل زاويه
ترى 5% ترى 5%
انا اعطيها مثال
5% كانك في مسبح واقف على اطراف اصابع كل
مويه لهنا اي نزول في المبيعات حتغرق ترى
خطير هذا الكلام
5% على الفرع ولا على الشركه الشركه كامله
يعني انت تبيع بمليار انت ربحك 50 مليون
طبعا بالنسبه لهم خارجه طبعا لانه يبيعون
بالارقام لكن لو صار عنده اي دروب
يعني حيكون خسران
بشكل كبير فما فيه يعني الارقام مبيعات او
الارباح اللي يذكرونها الناس غير موجوده
وانا لو هذا الارقام موجوده ترى كان معي
برشا على طريق الملك فهد وموقف لمبرجيني
عند الباب وحده طبعا
طيب وش المصاريف او التكاليف اللي الناس
ما تتبالها تكون هي مخفيه
تظهر لك بعد ما تبدا التشغيل فانت تقدر
تحسب انه مثلا اذا بتبدا تحسب مثلا
الخضروات اللي بتحطها ولا اللحم يعني
ورسوم حكوميه وغيرها بس بدون فيه احيانا
تكون في مصاريف انت ما تنتبه لها
هي قائمه طويله
يعني لعلنا ما ادري والله اذا عندكم منصه
ممكن نرسل لكم بعض البيانات تنشرونها ابدا
لكن هي قائمه انا حصلتها تقريبا يمكن حدود
35 بنت اللي عرفته هو سموه يسمونها او
التكاليف المخفيه ما سميت مخفيه الا لانها
بالفعل مخفيه عن الناس ما يشربها الا في
لحظه قد يكون فات الوقت المناسب لمعالجتها
لكن واحده من اهم الاشياء اللي هو مساله
التالف والهدر
في مساله يسمونها
او خلنا نقول الانحراف المعياري في
الانتاج اعطيك مثال واضح اليوم عندك تشتري
عشره كيلو من صدور الدجاج للشاورما
لكل واحد من الزملاء يطلع تقريبا 20% هدر
يقول بس افك التجميد يعني العشره كيلو بس
افك التجميد ما نظفت باقي يقول فيه يمكن
من كيلو الى اثنين كيلو تروح هذي بس فكه
التجميد بعض العصورات الموجوده والمويه
حقت التجميد وكذا راحت طيب هذه معناها
ارتفاع في التكلفه انت اشتريت ثمانيه كيلو
بقيمه عشره هذه احدى التكاليف المخفيه
اللي ممكن تكون موجوده واحده طبعا
الشاورما تعتبر اصعب انا في وجهه نظري
اصعب بنشاط ممكن اشتغل فيه احد لانه في
الانتاج في كثير من الهدر والتكاليف
المخفيه اللي ما يشعر بها صاحب المحل لفه
الشاورما على السيخ في جزء ما ينباع هذا
لازم يتقطع ويرمى هذا ما يحسبونه بعض
الشباب
ويصبح عليه تكلفه وهو ما يشعر ثم يطلع
مثلا في قوائم الدخل والله انا ربحاني
يطلع لنا المحاسب
الباشا انه ربحان وبس يقول في الحساب وين
انا مشترياتي اعلى من الارقام المعياريه
اللي عندي واحده من التكاليف المخفيه مثلا
ما يحسبوا مثلا تذكره تذكره العامل
والنظام ينص على انه انت مسؤول انك تجيب
العامل وترجعه الى بلده في وقت الاجازات
طيب يعني ما حسبها في في تكاليفه واحده
متكاليف ايضا موضوع نهايه الخدمه
مثلا من التكاليف
ما سميها مخفيه معلش ممكن نبلش على احد
اليوم نبرش ما سمينا المخفيه انا سميها
هذه
الجوائح التي تصيب الناس اللي يصير مثلا
من اجابه انا اليوم مثلا ابني البزنس حقي
انه هذا هو يجيني اجاده تغرمني 15,000
والله في ناس ربحه الشهري ما يجي عشره
الاف ريال وين يدفع ال15
فهذه من التكاليف المخفيه او الغير متوقعه
لتظهر لك في البيزنس وقد تسبب شلل او فشل
هذا في لقاء اليمين
منطقه الرياض
كل ما زادت فلوسهم بس يغيرون علشان تقل
هذه الاشياء ارجو يعني انا اعرف انه
الوزاره مهتمه جدا وجالسه تسمع الصوت بشكل
جيد وحقيقه احنا رافعين صوتنا بكل قوه
يعني في كل مكان لكي يشاهدون بالفعل حجم
الضرر اللي احنا نعانيه من اجابه مخالفتك
اول امس جاتني مخالفه ب15 الف ريال
عدم في مدد عدم رفع
رواتب موظفين فراسلتهم قلت يا اخي الموظف
اللي موجود عندي هذا على انا مستاجره من
شركه والشركه هي اللي تحولها راتبه
ما هو انا
فمعليش طيب نعالجه طيب لو ما انا ما كلمت
واحد دفعها 15 الف ما عنده مشكله
بس المره الاولى الثانيه الثالثه تصير 15
فكل مره اجيهم يلا عدلوا هاتوا وجيبوا
فهذي واحده من تكاليف المخفيه
فهذه تكاليف مخفيه الناس
طيب انا اليوم بفتح محل قلت لي قبل شوي
يعني اخذت يعني معلوماتي واتوقع ان عندي
شيء اقدر اقدمه واحس انه منتج حلو كذا
وش النصائح للمفترض اني التزم فيها للدخول
الى السوق
طيب انا اذا كنت لانه في ناس يجربون وفي
ناس
يعني ما تيسر لها وظيفه او كذا وقال خلني
أروح المدرسه فاللي يجرب يعني زي ما قلنا
نجرب اجمع المعلومات تستطيع وجرب باقل
تكلفه تستطيع حتى في التجربه لا يكون همك
انك تربح التجربه انك تتعلم وتشوف وتعرف
عشان بعد التجربه تبدا بشكل صحيح اللي
يبغى يبدا بزنس هذا هذه النصيحه ايضا
مقدمه له اذا يستطيع يعني لانه ما عنده
وظيفه مثلا اذا تستطيع عندك قدره ماليه
جرب ما تستطيع يا اخي اصحاب المطاعم
والمقاهي يقدمون لك دورات مجانيه بل
يعطونك فلوس فوقها تعال توظف يا اخي ادخل
الان مطاعم المقاهي شوف انت تبغى تصير زي
مين ابغى اصير زي ماكدونالدز ادخل
ماكدونالدز
ولا توقف الا اذا دخلت
خلنا نقول اروقت الاداره لانه ترى اللي
يصير في المطاعم غير اللي يصير في الاداره
يصير في المطاعم يعني تشغيل بحث فما بتشوف
صناعه القرار كيف تصير انت تنفذ القمر بس
هنا تتعلم التشغيل وتشوف ايش التفاصيل
حقتها بس لازم بعدين اذا تبغى تفتح بزنس
مستقر تروح الى مرحله مشاهده القرار كيف
يتم صنعه فلازم توصل الى مستويات اداريه
في الاداره فانا نصيحتي يا اخي خذ لك من
عمرك سنتين ثلاث اربع سنوات ما هو ما هو
عيب ولو خطا وترى بفلوس يعني ما هو بلاش
الين تتعلم التفاصيل هذه انا بعد هذا اضمن
بعد توفيق الله سبحانه وتعالى انه الشخص
اذا تعلم بشكل جيد انه يشترى
بالملايين يجونا مستثمرين يقول تعال هذا
مليون اثنين مليون انت بس نبغاك تشغل
المبالغ هذه واليوم موجود في السوق انا في
السناب اعلنت قلت يا جماعه اللي فتح مطعم
ولكن بعد كورونا ما حالفه الحظ وفشل
يراسلني
مئات الرسائل
طبعا هذا على جوال الخاص بالسناب جوالي
الخاص عشرات الرسائل من تجار يقول محمد
اللي ما تبغاه حوله لنا نبغاه نبغاه نبغاه
هذه عمله نادره المطلوبه في السوق صاحب
تجربه فاهم عارف فلوسك خلف في جيبك فلوس
فلوس يعني فلوس بمعنى فلوس بس يبغون الشخص
اللي فاهم ما تستطيع تفهم بالشكل الصحيح
الا تدخل منشات قائمه بشكل صحيح لو دخلت
انا عندك وانت عارف اني جالس تتعلم
بتوظفني اتكلم انا شخصيا انا عندي كل
الموظفين السعوديين اقول ما بقدرش عندي
انا بكره ابغى افتح انا واياك مشروع
بكره ابغى افتح معاك مشروع ثاني اكون انا
شريك كثير وانت مشغل ومثير بالعافيه عليك
طيب اذا ما عندي اذا نبغى اسوي راس المال
هل الخطا اني اخذاها عن طريق تمويل بنك
انت مين
بسوي تجربه لنفرض اني
بس انت يعني عارف امورك مجرب وكذا ولا توك
تبغى تجرب مجرب يلا طيب خلني اجيب اذا انت
تبغى تجرب وما عندك الخبره السابقه انا
اقول ابدا انتبه ولذلك يمكن شفنا اخر
نشره وزاره العدل
ظهر والله ناسي الارقام لكن خمسين في
المئه او اكثر تعثر في الالتزامات
والتنفيذ عليهم تنفيذ معناها ايش ايقاف
خدمات ايقاف حساباتك البنكيه من السفر
ليه لانه تعثر في السداد
فهذا الناس اللي ترى عندهم اساسا بزنس
شغالين بس ظروف كورونا وبعد كورونا تعثروا
فانا اقول ابدا التمويل حتى للشباب اللي
في البزنس الان لا تروح تمويل
ابدا لو تبغى تتوسع يا اخي دخل معك
مستثمرين في ناس اليوم يبحثون عن فلسطين
مستثمرين موجودين صح انه ما هو بالسهوله
اللي نتوقعها الحصول عليهم لكن صدقني اذا
كنت ناجح حيجونك الى عندك فانت لا تبدا
بفلوسك ابدا بفلوس الناس واشتغل بفلوس
الناس اتق الله بس فيما بينك وبين الناس
وابشر بالخير
فلذلك ما انصح به البته الا شركات كبيره
يعني عندها القدره الماليه والائتمانيه
نتغطي هذا التمويل ممتاز طيب هل ابدا
علامه جريه جديده ولا اخذ حق امتياز
لعلامه احبها وعندها انتشار طيب
شوف
خلنا نتكلم كمفهوم بعدين ادخل واقع كمفهوم
انك تاخذ علامات تجاريه وتشغلها فيها خير
كبير لذلك ترى اغلب
اغلب مثلا مشاهير امريكا اغلب لاعبين
رياضيين ممثلين كلهم شغالين بنظام
وياخذون دخل اعلى من وظيفتهم الاساسيه
اللي هو مثلا تمثيل او الرياض او غيرها
بشكل عالي جدا هذه استقراء بسيطة عملتها
في السوق الامريكي
في الوطن العربي والخليج في مثل الشائع
بعده تقريبا ما عنده ولا اظن عنده واحد او
اثنين ويملكها
البزنس الاساسي عنده هو كله العلامات
التجاريه عالميه
هذا كمفهوم عام ككونست اي نعم مقبول جدا
كوافع ما انصح ابدا اليوم مشكلتنا في
السوق وطبعا ما هو خطا في السوق السعودي
يعني هذا احنا في السوق السعودي
التجربه حديثه
يكون فيها مثل الاشكالات هذه
لا يوجد الى الان في السوق يمكن براند
براندين يعني مروا علي على الاقل شغال
بشكل جيد واقدر اقول هذا لو عندهم نموذج
جيد الباقي للاسف ما في شيء واقول ما اقول
لا تاخذون لكن اقول اعمل دبل تشيك يعني
شيك مره مرتين وثلاثه استشر الناس تاكد
بالفعل مئه في الميه انه هذا البراند صالح
يعني اليوم في كثير من الشباب والزملاء
المستشارين في مجال الفرشايز يعطونك
النصيحه يعني يفحصون معاك الفرصه ويتاكدون
من عليه لانها في شيء تشغيلي في شيء مالي
في شيء تسويقي
وفي شيء خلينا نقول انتشار او جغرافي يعني
مناسب او لا هذه كلها ممكن المستشارين هذا
يكون عندهم الخبره الكافيه يعطونك الراي
السليم ايش اللي يخلي تجربه الامتياز في
السعوديه بهذا السوء
ما اقدر اقول بهذا السوء لكنها تجربه
حديثه ودائما الشيء في بدايتها اذا ما في
الا علامتين اللي انت تقول انها تستحق انك
تاخذ امتياز يعني في مشكله ويش العلامه
[ضحك]
اللي انا شفته صراحه
يعني هذه واحد منها الثاني
يعني الى الان ما نقول اسمه لاني جالس
افحصه الى الان كويس بس اخشى ان ما هو هذا
لكن بوكس يمكن هو العلامه اللي شفتها الى
الان ممتازه العلامه الثانيه برجر لكن
يحتاج الى
النموذجه ما هو برجر عادي برجر خلنا نقول
فخمه شويه طيب انا باخذ المشروع اللي انت
قلت له
الامتياز فيه بيكون ممتاز ايش اللي خلاك
تقول ان هذا اذا اخذت حق الامتياز لهذا
المطعم طيب بيكون ممتاز عشان بفهم الاخرين
هو راس الحربه دائما في الفرنشايز هو مالك
المشروع واللي يديرون المشروع قتل اهم ناس
فاذا كانوا هذول الناس متشربين متشبعين
حريصين على مشروعهم فاهمين تفاصيله هذولا
خايفين اساسا انه احد يفشل
فسيلقى الممنوح يعني دعم كبير شخصي على
مستوى الشخصي يتكلم وبحيث انه ما يفشل
ابدا هذا واحد هذا الناس اذا كانوا حريصين
لن يسمحون لك انك تتجاوز لانه اليوم ترى
فشل الفرنشايز ما هم المانحين فقط
الممنوحين جزء كبير يعني عليهم فيه خطا في
في طريقه اخذ الفرنشايز ومزاولته فلن
يسمحوا لك تتجاوز الخطوط الحمراء لانه هذا
يعتبرونا براندوم فما يفرطون فيه فنقول
مثلا اول شيء الاداره يعني وفق الله في
اداره جيده هذا اول واهم عنصر تروح بعدين
الى النموذج الموجود نموذج في شقه تشغيلي
ومالي تتاكد تشغيليا العمليات سهله ما
فيها تعقيدات كثير انه
واضح ومفهوم وعدد عماله يمكن احتوائه ما
في مساحات كبيره ومشاكل كثيره وعمليات هذا
التشغيل المالي انه مربح فاذا بعت اذا
طلعت عندك لانه في شيء اضافي غير اللي
تكلمنا فيه اذا طلعت تكلفه مباشره والغير
مباشره وتكلفه الامدادات واللوجستيات
وتكلفه
بعد هذه كامله على المبيعات المتحفظه
بتكون ربحان معناها انت تشغيليا ماليا
تجاوزت
الاختبار المستوى الشيء الثالث اللي هو
الخدمه خدمه ما بعد البيع الخدمه
اللوجستيه والدعم اللي يجي من الشركه
فالمواد تصلك مغلفه مضبوطه يعني في حصص
واضحه واضح التدريب اللي يجيك
الدعم خلني اقول المعرفي مثل الدعم في
معرفه الماليه في حساب التكاليف في قائمه
الدخل وغيرها فهذا الدعم واللوجيسيات
اخيرا
البراند قابل للتسويق قابل للانتشار
جغرافيا ما عنده مشاكل فيقدر ينتشر
جغرافيا ومقبول انه يتم تسويقه في المناطق
الجغرافيه هذه تقريبا اربع مستويات اذا
تاكدت منها الامور الشرطه طيبه متى ابني
اعلان تجاري الخاصه اخذ حق الامتياز
والله اذا اذا في فرنشات زي ذكرناه قبل
شوي انا سحبت
حيختصرون عليك 70% من صداع المطاعم كثير
من الممنوحين اليوم
بدا يعني بزنس في المطاعم وما شاء الله
تبارك الله ناجحين فيه وشغالين بشكل جيد
بس وين تعلم في البدايه تعلم في الفرنشايز
فاذا في فرشايز شديد جيد انا انصح تبدا
فيه بعدين ابدا بعلامتك الخاصه ممتاز طيب
انا الحين قررت اني اخذ علامتي الخاصه لان
يبدون فيها هي
تعبت اكثر
دائما تقولون على هندسه قائمه الطعام وانه
لازم تسويه ومدري كيف وكذا
فما مدى دقه هالكلام يعني ما مدى ادق صحه
هذه الكلام اتذكر في وحده من تغريدات يمكن
عندك اتوقع كان
فيعني شكل المنيو وين تحط في قائمه الطعام
وانت تحط الصوره وان تحط الاكل لانه اللي
في اليسار يكون عليه اكثر
اليوم كله في الكيو ار كود وتصور وما عاد
تدري ايش اختلفت فهل فعلا هندسه قرن
الطعام في غير العلامات التجاريه الكبرى
اللي عندها يعني لما نتكلم
يعني هذه الشركات اللي عندها فريق متخصص
في هذا الموضوع
سيكولوجيا وسلوك المستخدم وكذا هل فعلا
شيء مفترض الواحد ينتبه له ولا هو كلام
حلو وتجاوزه
طيب على كل حال احنا نتكلم بنظريات طيب ما
يمكن نظرياتنا تنطبق على الجميع لكن حاول
في اغلب الكلام اللي يدعمها بتجارب هندسه
قائمه الطعام هي نظريات موجوده عمل فيها
في كثير من البراندات والعالم شكل يعني
متسع واثبتت نجاحها هل تنطبق هنا نظريه
ممكن تنطبق مكلف لكن نجي للتجارب
صحيح انه بدا الكيوركات وتطبيقات التوصيل
ايضا تعتبر قائمه طعام فاحيانا تحتاج الى
هندسه خاصه
قائمه الطعام في
تطبيقات التوصيل تؤثر بشكل كبير على قرار
العميل
يعني اعطيك مثلا مثال انا عندي جاهز
مرتب جاهز بطريقه ومرتب هنقرستيشن بطريقه
وازعم ان سلوك العميل هنا وهنا شبه متقارب
اللهم انه هذا انا هنقرستيشن احسن لي وهذا
لكن في الاخير سلوك واحد
في هنقرستيشن ويعمل تحليل وجدته متوسط
الفاتوره
والله اظن 96 ريال
في جاهز
180 ريال
فرق كبير تعالوا يا جماعه وش القصه
فتحنا القائمتين وجدت انه في هذيك الفتره
كان اللحم والدجاج في جاهز في البدايه
وهنا كان في خطا من الشباب فكاه الايدامات
والسلطات في البدايه
فاثر بشكل كبير على سلوك العميل هذه تجربه
واقعيه انا اشتري لذلك اقول نعم هندسه
نظري غيرتها
غيرت انا وتغيرت الفواتير غيرناها قبل
رمضان صراحه يعني
اليوم جايني تقارير اقول كل يوم لازم
ترسلوا لي كم فاتوره متوسطه الفواتير بس
ما طلعت اعتقد اليوم
لكنه لما وجدنا التحليل ما كان في اي يعني
تبرير الا هذا بعد التغيير اتوقع انه
بالفعل هذا هو السبب هندسه قائمه الطعام
نعم تؤثر بشكل كبير وكثير من الزملاء يعني
جرب وفرقت معاه طبعا قائمه الطعام او
هنستلم طبعا اذا صحت الترجمه
يعني الممارساتها غير هذه ايضا يعني مثلا
تاخذ
هي نتيجه هندسه قائمه الطعام تطلع لك اربع
النجمه
والحصان والكلب اكرمكم الله وعلامه
الاستفهام
هذه النتائج حقتها باختصار تطلع لك اربع
اصناف الاعلى مبيعا والاعلى ربحا الاعلى
مبيعا والاقل ربحا الاقل مبيعا والاعلى
ربحا الاقل مبيعا والاقل ربحا هذه اربع
اصناف حيصنفها لك هندسه تبدا الان انت
تتخذ اجراء مع هذا الامر اللي يطبقوا هذا
الامر حصلوا على نتائج مرضيه بشكل جيد
بعضهم رفع الربحيه
الى تقريبا 20 25% ليش لانه اكتشف انه
عنده عشره اصناف في قائمه علامه الاستفهام
اللي هي الاقل مبيعا ولا اقل ربحا ماخذه
عليه مكان في المطبخ وفي المخزن والمستودع
والعامل والمبيعات والهدر
والعميل غير راضي ومنها القبيل فلما
الغاها ما الغى العميل ووجه العميل الى
اصناف اخرى
اكثر ربحيه افضل تحققت له ربحيه اعلى ما
في عميل ترك المطعم لانه الغى الاصنف هذه
هل هل بالفعل الواقع اي نعم الواقع يشهد
انها لها تاثير
طيب
المطعم اللي عنده وجبه واحده مقابل المطعم
متعدد الوجبات
مؤخرنا من انصار المطعم اللي عنده وجبه
واحده ولا اقول اني هذا هو الصح لكنني كذا
استقراء اقول المطعم اللي عنده وجبه واحده
دائما وجبه هذه حتكون لذيذه جيده
مستهدف عميل واضح
اذا احد فكر مثلا في الشوايه يظهر اسمه
الاول لانه معروف انها ركز على الشوايه
والاهم طبعا هذا العميل الاهم انه مساحات
صغيره عماله قليله عمليه تشغيليه اقل
تسويق مركز
اداره خلاص واضحه وبسيطه عمليات ماليه
محدده فهذه كلها تعطيك قله في التكاليف
قله الاخطاء
الخطا تكلفتها وهذه احدى التكاليف المخفيه
فانا من انصار هذه المدرسه الجديده
طيب بالنسبه للموظفين ابي اعتقد في مشكله
انا اغلب
الموظفين في المطاعم عماله غير سعوديه
وما ادري يعني ما ادري كيف تختارون هم
كتدري انه هذا الموظف بيكون موظف ممتاز
للعمال السعوديه
يعني في شح في
الموظفين المتميزين في هذا المجال فهم
عاده موظفين طلبه او ناس تبغى تقضي وقت
وتمشي فما هو وظيفته اللي يحرسن يطور نفسه
ويكون افضل واحد فيها فكنت تعملون معاهم
انها
طيب خل نبدا نغير السعوديين غير السعوديين
لهم مستويات يعني ففي ناس مثلا
مدراء تشغيل في ناس مداره مطابخ في ناس
شفات في ناس عماله عاديه اليوم في على
مستوى العالم مكاتب متخصصه في استقطاب
كل المستويات من عامل عادي الى مقدم الى
اعلى المستويات موجودين هذولا ولو بحث اي
واحد في المجتمع اللي حوله او في النت او
كذا وجد المكاتب هذه
الثاني اللي هو السعوديين ما في تحدي في
هذا الجانب
لكنه في الاخير طريقه واضحه حتى تتواصل مع
مكاتب متخصصه جربوها احد من اصحابك او شفت
لهم اعلانات وتبدا ترسل لهم الطلبات هم
يبداون يبحثون يجيبون لك ممكن انت تروح
خاصه بعض الموظفين المهمين اللي في تعامل
مباشر بينك وبينه هذا لازم تاكد فيه
كاريزما
فيها تقارب في الشخصيات فلازم تروح
وتقابلهم العمل اللي ما في تعامل مباشر
بينك وبينهم يبدا مثلا مقابلات شخصيه
بالزوم وكذا وهذه مفيده جدا فهذا طريقتها
السعوديين
طبعا طبيعه السوق انه
التحول فيه كبير
في بشكل عالي وهذا حتى لا هنا ولا خارج
السعوديه
فطبيعي جدا انه يكون فيه
يعني لذلك انا اقول في السعوديين لازم
تتعامل معهم بطريقه اما انك تحطها في مكان
لو راح تلقى البديل مكانه بشكل سريع كاشير
تويتر
او انك تتعامل معه انه هذا الانسان انا
ابني فيه مشروع مشروع انسان فلازم تهتم
فيه
وطبعا اثنين موجوده واثنين ليست خطا هذاك
طالب جامعه يبغى يدخل اضافي تيجي الله
يبارك له وفي واحد لا هو يبغى يبني مشروع
الحياه هذا لازم تهتم فيه وتتابع معه
وتطور بشكل جيد طيب فتحت فرعي
ما تفتح
الفرع الثاني انا اقول هو الاختبار الصعب
اصعب شيء الفرع الثاني اصعب الفرع الاول
ليه لان الفرع الاول دائما نفتحه واذا
نجحنا فيه بعد توفيق الله نكتشف انها من
اسباب يمكن ما كانت تخطر لنا على البال
نبدا ننتبه لها الفرع الثاني هذا اختبار
لك انه هل الاسباب هذه صحيحه صحيحه او لا
متى تفتح اذا اصبح الفرع الاول في
الاستقرار المادي اللي يتحمل انشاء الفرع
الثاني ولا يؤثر عليه لو خسر
انت عندك مثلا دخل وجمعت رصيد للفرع
الثاني
فتفتح منها الفرع الثاني لو فشل الفرع
الثاني الفرع الاول ما يتاثر ماليا ولا
تشغيليا هنا اقول لك افتح القناه الثانيه
يعني بعد مرحله استقرار كبير جدا من الفرع
الاول وهذه مرحله استقرار كم تاخذ وقت زمن
ولا فلوس بس
لا لا انا ارى انها حاجتين فلوس وتشغيل
اداره وتشغيل يعني
هذه ممكن تاخذ سنه ممكن تاخذ سنتين ثلاث
سنوات ممكن تاخذ سته شهور في بعض النماذج
اللي ما هي معقده وربحيتها يعني عاليه وفق
الله ان يكون عندها دخل جديد ربحيتها
الثاني في الرياض طالع بس في الرياض ثاني
في شيء يسمونه معلش سامحني على الافضل
يسمونه لعنه المعرفه
كل ما كنت عارف اكثر كل ما كنت تخاف اكثر
ولا انا اجد عتب كبير والله لا من داخل
السعوديه وين مخارج السعوديه من المعارف
اللي يعرفوني ليش ما تنتشر ليش ما تروح
الفرع الثاني لكن المعرفه هذه اللي تشبعنا
فيها سرنا نخاف فاحيانا الا تعرف قد يكون
افضل انا انا اللي مخليني ما اروح الفرع
الثاني هو الخوف هذا
فتخاف من الاشخاص تخاف من الفشل
طبعا انك جالس تشوف اشياء انت ترى انك ما
حققتها الى الان من زياده المثاليه انا
اقول يعني ولا عندي شعور داخلي يقول لا لا
ترى انت امورك تمام روح الفرع الثالث لا
تخاف باذن الله الامور طيبه فرع اذا انت
جالس تفكر فيه قصدك تاخر
طيب متى
اقفل المطعم
او مقال طيب فيه في نقطه يسمونها في
الاقتصاد يقول يسمونها نقطه الاغلاق نقطه
الاغلاق هذه ماليه اتكلم مالي بحث انه اذا
اصبحت تبيع وتخسر
تبيع مبيعاتك ما تغطي تكاليف التشغيل
فهنا لازم تبدا تفكر جديا بالاغلاق
وتحط الاغلاق خلاص هذا خيار على الطاوله
طيب متى استخدم هذا الورقه بعد ما ابذل
الجهد اللي استطيعه ماليا
تشغيليا تسويقيا تطوير استثمار اجيب
مستثمر يضخ معاي مثلا استفدت هذا كامل لا
تتردد ابدا في الاغلاق واليوم انا اقول
التاجر الناجح ليس اللي يعرف كيف يفتح
اللي يعرف كيف يتخارج باقل الخسائر او
باعلى الارباح انا هذا هو التاجر الناجح
اللي ارى انه
طيب الان اذا المشروع شغال مضطريت اني
اقفل ودي اعرف الاشياء الجانبيه يعني خارج
عن التشغيل التسويق مثلا
مش ابرز السلوكيات التسويق اللي موجوده
مثلا عندنا
الخاطئه والجيده
نحصرها في مثلا هذا النقاش لكن خلني اتكلم
اطلع فوق شويه مثلا اعطيها النظره
الشموليه اكثر مشكله التسويق اليوم انه
احنا كاصحاب مطاعم لسنا مسوقين
فالتسويق بالنسبه لنا نعتبره عالم مبهم ما
نفهم فيه بشكل كبير
واذا رحنا نبغى نسوق حنقصر في النشاط
الاساسي حقنا اذا بغينا ندخل في العمليات
هذه هذا الجانب الاخر ان المسوقين
في ناس جايين كويسين وكذا لكن جاينا مدرسه
التسويق الالكتروني المتاجر الالكترونيه
يعني غالبا فما هم واعين بشكل كبير جدا
لمساله المطاعم عاكس على سبيل المثال كيف
يكون التسويق فيها
فانا بيني وبينهم شويه يعني مناحله فانا
احاول اقول لا تقول لي والله انا اعطيك
وعي علامتك التجاريه انا لا لا انا تاجر
يهمني حاجه واحده كيف اقدر ابيع
اذا تسوق لي ما ينعكس هذا على مبيعاتي
بشكل مباشر خلينا نقول خلال فتره معينه
انا هذا ما اعتذر بالنسبه للتسويق ناجح
ليه لانه كلف علي وما جابلي مبيعات
فهذه اشكاليه التسويق اليوم مدرستين اليوم
جالسه تتقارب يعني بشكل اخر ولازم تتقارب
عشان يستفيدوا من بعض لكن ارجع اقول انا
نحتاج التسويق بشكل جيد ونحتاج الشباب
هذولا بشكل كويس ولازم بس لازم يسمعوا لنا
انا عندي احد الشباب مسوق اول ما جاني كان
في المدرسه هذه حاولت افهمه اي مدرسه
مدرسه المتاجر الالكترونيه وعي ومدري ايش
وكذا فقلت له لا لا اوكي مقبول لكن انا
برسل لك يوميا مبيعاتي
وابغى اشوف انت الحمل اللي تسويها ايش
اثرها على المبيعات
حبه حبه بدا يدخل معاي في مساله الارقام
وبدا يلاحظ انه انا لما اعمل تسويق على
جوجل ماب بالطريقه الفلانيه يبدا يصير
عندنا الاثر بعد اسبوع زياده في الزيارات
وزياده في المبيعات اعطيته يعني
على كل البيانات الماليه يعرف ارباحنا
وخسائرنا ومبيعاتنا ويعرف كل حاجه فبداوا
يتشرب الفكره هذه وبدات اجد اجد انا منها
النتيجه اللي انا ابغاها مش كان يسوي
اشياء خطا وما تنعكس على اي ارقام
مثلا لما يقول حمله السناب ويعمل فاصل في
السناب السناب هذا اوكي عرف الناس بس ما
حد جانا ما حد رفع الشاحن الشاشه ما حد
اشترى طيب وش المفترض المفترض يا اخي انك
يعني مثلا مثلا كانوا بعض مسوقين يصور
والله مثلا يحط الصحه وتحته حاجه كذا
انت تعطيني صوره قريبه من اللحم وانت تقطع
اللحمه مع الرز وكيف يتناثر هذا الشيء
اللي بالنسبه لي اعرف ان عميلي سيتخذ
القرار ويشتري
سابقا هو لاعب الصوره جميله اليوم ما
يهمها جمال الصوره يهمه تفاصيل هذه اللي
تعمل قرار العميل يعني هذه وحده مثلا من
الممارسات الاعلان مع المشاهير
التواصل الاجتماعي المشاهير لهم اثر كبير
جدا ويحققون مبيعات عاليه على الاقل يمكن
قطاع كان يدخلهم في مساله المطاعم ويخافون
منه الحساسيه المطاعم مع العملاء لان ذاقت
الناس لا يمكن تتفق مهما كانت
لهم تاثير الى فتره قريبه ثم هذا التاثير
بدا ينزل بشكل واضح حتى عند المتاجر
الالكترونيه بدات تاثير المشاهير ينزل
بشكل كبير ويقول مثلا اذا بعطي مشهور
اربعين خمسين الف انا ممكن اصمم حمله
اعلانيه
على كل وسائل التواصل عروض انزلها على
العملاء كوبونات او غيره حتى تجيب لي مثلا
اثر اكبر وعائد اكبر مساله اشهر جربت مع
احد المشاهير
جربت مع واحد من الزملاء وكان اثرها جيد
وطبعا اسمه قوي في المطاعم الله يبارك له
كان اثره جيد بقيه مشاهير بعضهم في علاقه
شخصيه فيجي جزاها الله خير يعلم مجانا
يمكن واحد
مجموعهم يمكن سبعه ثمانيه اشخاص بس واحد
اللي كان له اثر الباقيه ولا شيء
هذول الناجحين
يعني من 30 الى 50% لمده خمس ايام سبع
ايام ثم يرجع بس ما يرجع زي اول يرجع عشره
في المئه زياده عشره في المئه
كملت لطالما الاثر
لعبه ارقام انا هذا صرفت عليه كذا انا لو
صرفتها في السوشيال ميديا وهذا حجيب الرقم
اللي
هذه الاماكن اللي تصرف عليها يعني مثلا
السناب فواصل السعوديه لغيتها يعني هذه
بديل المشاهير
الانستجرام والبوستات التيك توك
والهاشتاقات اللي تصير فيه وترويج بعض
المقاطع التي تصور عندنا وهذه مفيده جدا
اشرح لك
التيك توك
طبعا هو التجربه جديده لا احد ياخذ
بالكلام هذا تجربتي شخصيه التيك توك جتنا
وحده
ودخلت المطعم ما اعرفها صراحه لكن المطعم
الحمد لله يعني سمعتها جيده فصورت وكذا
وفي المجلس عندنا مجلس شويه مرتب صورت
الباب وتسحب الباب ودخلت المجلس نزلتها في
التيك توك
ما نعرف عن القصه هذه تماما الا لما امتلا
المطعم عندنا يا شباب عملتوا حمله قالوا
ما سوينا شيء طيب شوفوا لي منين الناس
وين هو طلعت البنت هذه طبعا بعدين عملنا
لها ضيافه وكذا وصارت كل فتره تنزلنا
تيك توك احيانا يبهرك واحيانا تصل مليون
مشاهده ما في اي اثر هذا احد الزملاء عمل
حمله وصلت مليون مشاهده ما في ولا اثر انا
دخلت على حسابي وعملت ترويج المقطع عادي
مو في المطاعم وشفت التفضيلات
شفت التفضيلات وحطيت الترويج الرياض
اغلب التفضيلات بالهند
بنغلاديش
اغلب الاضافات
الى لحظه ابغى اشوف وش الخطا ما اعرف تيك
توك فيه يعني اثر بس ما اقدر اقول لك كيف
يكون اثرها بشكل جيد بس اللي عملناه احنا
انه بدينا حطينا هاشتاق وقلنا للي يجي
يصور حط في الهاشتاج احنا نتروج مقطعه على
حسابنا فهو يستفيد انه حسابه تروج واحنا
نستفيد من مقطعنا
تجربه البنت هذه كم منعكس على مبيعاتك
يمكن
والله يمكن 12 يوم او 11 يوم بنسبه يمكن
ثلاثين في المئه كمتوسط في ايام عاليه لكن
المتوسط يمكن 30% او اكثر
الرياض فيه ميزه مختلفه عن جده غيره
الرياض فيه ناس
اللي هم المهتمين بالمطاعم هذول المؤثرين
بشكل جيد ضعفوا مؤخرا لانه رخصه موثوق
بعضهم ما عنده استطاع يطلعها
فتوقف عن الاعلام ولا قبل رخصه موثوق قال
لهم اثر ممتاز جدا والاثر اكثر عند اللي
مثلا متابعين في تويتر وعنده حساب في
التيك توك وايضا السناب او يصور وينزل
تويتر وسناب وتيك توك كلهم اثر جيد جدا
وهذولا في بدايه المطعم عندنا كان احد
الوسائل اهتمينا فيها تويتر
في ناس
ميزه تويتر انه يحفظ
يعني مهما كان تغريده موجوده يعني اليوم
انا كنت ابغى افطر كتبت افطار رمضان رحت
تويتر طبعا انا اشوف اليوم النصه الاولى
في البحث ما عاد صار جوجل صار تويتر فرحت
تويتر رمضاني بديت اشوف تغريدات من ايام
كورونا وقبل كورونا
في الفندق فاليوم ما حد يقدم بوكسر
رمضانيه فالتغريدات طلعت لي من ايام
كورونا الفتويتر هو تاريخي يعني يحفظ لك
الاعلام بشكل عام ويبدو لي حتى انه الحين
صار تيك توك مكان للبحث بالدرجه الاولى
عشان الناس تبحث عن اي شيء
بشكل كبير طيب بالنسبه لي خرائط جوجل
يبدو انها مهمه
طبعا في الاعلانات على جوجل قديش اثرها
ممتازه جدا ممتازه جدا
يعني هي هي القوه الناعمه صراحه وانا
اتوقع جوجل جاي الفتره القادمه بنموذج
اللي جالس انا اشوفها وكذا مراقبه انه
سيصبح هو النص الاولى لتوصيل الطلبات
واتوقع انه يسحب البساط من تحت تطبيقات
التوصيل
لانه
جالس يعمل كثير من الاشياء اللي تدل انه
في توجه اتجاه هذا الامر يعني مثلا خانه
خاصه بالعروض
انه يظهر في بدايه
البحث يطلع لك الشعار حقك على الخريطه
اكبر بحيث انه يكون فهو جالس يتجه لقطاع
التجاري بشكل او باخر طيب بالنسبه
للتقييمات فاصحاب المطاعم
اصحاب المطاعم دائما يطلعون بهذه الشكوى
انك انت تخرب مطعمي لا احد يكتب تعليق
يسوي يعني يخرب علي ممكن يدعي عليه بعضهم
يقول لك قضيه
مشكلتكم معاه التقييمات اللي تصير في
خرائط جوجل طيب أنا
مشكلتكم ترى هذي كلمه بالنسبه لي كبيره
لاني ما اقدر اتكلم الا عن نفسي
اقدر افهمك طيب
احنا انا شخصيا واتوقع اغلب الشباب ما
عندنا مشكله مع التقييمات اللي بنجمه وحده
الا اذا كانت مغرضه او غير مفيده
فمعناها ان اكيد جاك ومهتم انه يجيك
قدم لي بس خدمه وقول لي يا اخي انت
يا ما بقول كلمه عندكم مشكله واحد اثنين
ثلاثه اربعه خلني اعدل انا اليوم والله
استفيد من التقييمات ابو نجمه هذه اكثر من
التقييمات ابو خمس نجوم انا كصاحب مطعم بل
اني طورت من الانتقادات اكثر من الناس
اللي يمدحون انا ما ابغى اسمع مدح انا
اليوم مهم للانتقاد يهمني الفشل اتعلم منه
اكثر فيا اخي اذا حطيت نجمه حقك لا يمكن
احد يقول لك لا بس تكفى اكتب لي ليش نجمه
واذا كتبت
فخلاها بالفعل نجمه يعني لا تقول والله
انا جيت
صراحه كل شيء ممتاز بس يا اخي المغسله
عندهم ما كان فيه مويه حاره نجمه يا اخي
ايضا العداله في هذا
وطبعا النجمه تطيح تقييمك كثير يعني لازم
انبه على امر ليش يزعلون اصحاب المطاعم
لانه بالفعل هذا يؤثر في رزقه نعم اليوم
العميل بشكل كبير لا من داخل السعوديه ولا
خارج السعوديه جزء من قراره انا واحد منهم
يعتمد على تقييم
ادخل جوجل ماب واحد اعطاني توصيه ولو اثق
فيه ادخل جوجل ماب واشوف تقييمه
وعندي معيار كذا اذا كانت التقييمات لازم
تكون التقيات مثلا اكثر من 500 الى 700
ويكون التقييم فوق الاربعه يعني هذا
معياري الخاص فلما ادخل على مطعم مثلا في
700 800 وتقييم ثلاثه فاصله ثمانيه مثلا
ثلاثه فاصله خمسه ما اروح له فعلا متردد
يعني طيب هذا رزق عرفت كيف تؤثر هنا
المسؤوليه لك انت قطعت رزق الناس اذا صحت
الكلمه استغفر الله واتمنى يعني سلف
الاخير احيانا ايش اللي يخلي ان الناس
تقيمك لانه مره انت عاجبني او انك في
الارجاء على الارجح اني ما اقيم الا اذا
انت مره زعلتني
فتلقى ان الناس مو كلهم يقيمون لكنها فعلا
تؤثر على الرقم فاي احد تحت تردد جدا اني
اروح له بس يعني سنه تردد احيانا ودي اقيم
يعني ادخل في تجربه سيئه
انت اذا دخلت في تجربه سيئه بالفعل حقها
نجمه حط نجمه واكتب تعليقك بشكل واضح
اذا تواصل معاك المطعم ورد عليك التواصل
اعرف ان هذا المطعم في نظري يستحق اقل شيء
ثلاث نجوم الاهتمامه خلاص
الطريقه نرجع نتواصل نسمع منه نعرف الخطا
نعدل الخطا ونرضيه وجينا مره ثانيه حتى
نقول لا تعدل تقييمك ارجوك الا اذا جيت
مره ثانيه وتاكدت ان الخطا تعدل يعني مثلا
انا اول ما فتحت نكهه في الرياض ما كنت
استهدف العوائل ابدا
لكن يتفاجات من كميه العوائل بشكل كبير
فصار عندي اشكاليه في دورات المياه عندي
دورات مئه وحده او يعني بس مدخل واحد
صاروا الحريم والرجال مع بعض فبدت تجيني
تقييمات سلبيه
تلقائيا رحت فتحت دوره مياه ثانيه وفتحت
مغسله ثانيه
وردينا على الناس اننا اعتذر منكم لم يكن
مكان مصمم للعوائل لكن عوائل ما نقدر
نردهم ونحييهم الله يرحمهم يحييهم وفي
الاخير بدات تتعدل التقييمات بعد ما عدلنا
دوره المياه يعني هذه وحده من الاشياء
اللي اقول لك تجربه شخصيه لازم تستفيد
التقييمات السلبيه وتعدلها وبعد كذا كثير
من العملاء رجع وشاف المكان وعدل التقي
طيب انا تقييمات انا بقول لك بعدين كنت
بقيمك
[ضحك]
يعني رحت المطعم
زمان يعني انا احب اكلك والله
لذيذ جدا
يعني حتى في الاحتفال السنوي حق ثمانيه
طلبنا من عند اهله
فيعني الاكل بس اني جيت مره
وكان كانت عندنا العزيمه
جيت ابغى ابغى اخذ يعني باخذ الاكل
قرر انها مقفله وقت الصلاه العشاء يعني خذ
لك ثلاثين دقيقه ما اقدر اخده الرجال
ينتظرون ابغى اجيب لك يعني كان بعد العشاء
على طول يعني
بشكل لا يمكن يعني كذا الرياض هنا
كيف يمكن سنتين سنه
هذه كانت تجربه ما اعرف لكن احنا اليوم
اللي نسوي نتكلم عن اليوم
اعرف انا من اول ما فتحت في الرياض انا ما
اقفل وقت الصلاه أنا خلي العميل يدخل مجلس
يعطيني اه اوكي اوكي
احنا اللي احنا اللي نسويه عاده ان نفتح
الباب مفتوح العميل يجي نرحب به نقول له
انتظرنا بس نصلي ونرجع انا اقول انه يعني
ايضا في التجاره في جانب لازم نهتم فيه
هذا
الموظفينة عندنا ولو انا متاكد تماما لو
ما خليناهم نعطيهم وقت للصلاه
وندفعهم على مجال نسحبهم سحبا الى الجنه
ما سلموا ليش
ثقافه مثلا عنده او كذا يعني الله يعفو
عنا وعنهم احيانا احنا نسوي الشيء هذا بس
عشان لانهم يعتبر مسؤولين عنهم ندفعهم
لاداء يعني هذا الركن العظيم ان اركان
الاسلام بس في المقابل ما اقدر اخلي
العميل برا انا لازم احترم العميل لو دخلت
انت شفت انا حاب كراسي تحت الكنبه اللي
موجوده
ترى مبلغ كبير جدا الخشب والكذا ليه اهتم
في العميل اجلس في مكان جميل ومرتاح في
شاهي في خدمه عندك بس يخلصون الشباب
ويسلمونك الطلب هذه سياسه موجوده عندنا
والمره القادمه راسلني انا
[ضحك]
استخدمهم كثير
احسنهم مؤثرين كان في حلقه مؤخرا مع
مؤسسه تطبيق كارت
فيعني الحديث حول مشكله
توصيل الطلبات وقديش هم ياخذون من المطاعم
وكيف اثروا على زياده
تكلفه الاكل على العميل النهائي برضو كيف
اثروا اصحاب المطاعم برضو كثيره هل هذه
الكلام يعني حتى الظاهر وحده من اسباب
انخفاض ارباحها كانت جزء منها انه
التطبيقات التوصيل
وين الحل هل هذا هو خلاص هذا الشكل
الطبيعي اللي ممكن نستسلم له لانه
التطبيقات التوصيل تاخذ هذه النسبه واللي
هي تعتبر اقل من برا يعني
تقريبا
تتراوح ما بين 13% الى 25 تقريبا يعني من
25 الى ثلاثين يعني هذا نتكلم عنه في
امريكا وغيرها فهل هذا هو خلاص هذا هو
السوق وهذه المشكله مفترض انها ما تكون
مشكله ونتعامل معها ولا في حل ولا هي فعلا
ما لها اثر او اثر ودي تكلمنا الحديث عن
تطبيقات التوصيل الحديث جدلي
وفيه عده اطراف يعني
رافضين يتقاربون اتجاه بعض
وهي لازم ترى خطوه من هنا وخطوه من هنا
انا بحكم اني من اصحاب المطاعم فبتكلم
باسم اصحاب المطاعم
مشكله التطبيقات التوصيل
انه في بدايتها كان الموضوع
يعني بالنسبه لنا اضافه مبيعات
يعني احنا كنا مثلا شغالين وعندنا ارباحنا
وفوق نقطه التعادل فلما جاو يتكلمون معانا
قلنا اوكي خير على خير ما في مشكله
وين صارت المشكله من بعد كورونا ترى قبل
كورونا انا اتحدى اي واحد من التطبيقات
التوصيل كان يقول انه يسمع منه شكاوى لازم
من الشكاوى باي علاقه عمل حتى بينك وبين
موظفك لازم يصير في شكاوى لكن الشكاوى
بالشكل الحالي اللي احنا فيه ما كانت
موجوده ليش لانه ما كان فيه حجم مبيعات هم
يسيطرون عليه اليوم عندهم هيمنه بشكل كبير
على مبيعات بعض المطاعم مثلا في الرياض
تصل الى سبعين خمسه وسبعين في المئه هذه
الهيمنه مخيفه
احنا يصبحت اليوم انت لو تقفل علي ضغطه زر
هو ترى ضغطه زر بالفعل انا نهار طيب هذا
واحد من الاشياء اللي احنا نقول لازم يكون
فيه طرف ثالث يضبط العلاقه احنا اذا قلنا
طرف ثالث لهم يزعلون
لازم المشرع لازم
فهذا خلنا نقول مستوى الكبير الي نتكلم
عنه اللي هو انه اصبحوا هم مهيمنين على
مبيعات المطاعم طيب نجي للممارسات
الداخليه تطبيق التوصيل كان مهمته انه
يجيب عميل للمطعم عشان مطعم يبيع عليه
اليوم تطبيق التوصيل يقول لنا العميل
العميل
هذا حقي انا طيب ليش يا اخي نستثمر ملايين
ولا صحيح اسفين حقك طيب اهتم بعميلك انا
وش دخلني اذا صار فيه خطا من مندوب او
منكم او من كذا اتحمل انا كصاحب المطعم
تكلفه هذا الخطا
لا الخطا من المطعم سمعنا وطاعه الخطا
المطعم الحين اذا صار خطف الطلب انت اللي
تدفع انا انا ادفع اي خطا الطلب ابدا يمكن
في حاله واحده اذا المندوب بالفعل تاخر
التسليم لكن اذا العميل استلم الطلب اي
شكوى المطعم هو يتحملها
طيب
ما نقدر نقول له طيب هات الخطا يا اخي
علمني من هو العميل ايش كان الخطا فيه
خلني اسمع اعطني رقم العميل خليني اتواصل
معاه يعني انا استفيد من هذا الشيء وانا
اعوضه انا اعوضه ما يهمك لا لا هذا عميري
طيب بعد كده
عوضه ونزل في محفظتها مثلا مئه ريال من
نكهه تانيه
راح العميل المره اللي بعدها المئه ريال
اللي انا دفعتها له اشتراها من منافس حقي
من رومانسيه طيب يا اخي ما يصير كذا رجعه
لي انا اخطيت
هذه يعني بعض الممارسات هذه بعض الممارسات
الموجوده في تطبيقات التوصيل اللي تزيد
الاحتقان من اصحاب المطاعم تجاه التطبيقات
وانا اقول والله بس مشكله اصحاب التطبيقات
ينظرون للمطاعم للاسف بنظره فوقيه فاتكلم
بشكل شخصي رحت وجلست وكذا يتقابلون بكل
احترام ولطف نطلع ما كان هنتقابلنا
هذا بشكل شخصي رحت انا عضو في لجنه
المطاعم المقاهي في الغرفه التجاريه في
الرياض رحنا الشباب ما قصروا جزاهم الله
خير في الغرفه
وجلسنا مع التطبيقات كبرى التطبيقات
وابشروا حاضر وكذا ولا في اي شيء
وصلنا الى نصل الى المشرع نتكلم معه هنا
صراحه هم بداوا تعالوا خلونا نجلس مع بعض
لما رحنا مثل هيئه المنافسه لما رحنا لبعض
وزاره التجاره ونتكلم بخطابات بدا يقولون
تعالوا ايش تبغى منا ومن حقك هذه مشكله
التطبيقات مشكله التطبيقات هي النظره من
فوق لاصحاب المطاعم وتعديل بسيط في بعض
الممارسات داخل التطبيقات فقط هذا مش
التعديلات اللي بتخليكم مبسوطه
اول شيء مثلا عداله المنافسه انت في
التطبيق مانك هيمنت على مبيعاتنا فارجوك
لا تفضل واحد على واحد لانه هذا بيربح
وهذا بيخسر مثلا انا اليوم مشترك في
التطبيق
معناها لازم اظهر فوق انت عارف كم واصل
الان
70 مطعم
يعني لو انا العميل قدام باب مطعمي وفاتحه
التطبيق يبغى يطلب مني ما بيظهر له الا
بعد سبعين مطعم
مع انه انت تقول بالاقرب
طيب
اترك هذا انا توبلست وما اظهر ليه لانه
قرر واحد من الموظفين انه يقفل الزون هذه
بسبب يقول والله انتوا عندكم زحمه
فالمندوب ما يمديه يوصل عندك وياخذ الطلب
ويوصله للعميل يصير بارد فقفلنا منطقه
الزحمه هذه يا اخي سبعين في الميه مبيعاتي
على منصتك تقفل
يعني مشكلتي انا انه صار في زحمه في
المكان هذا انا جاي في المكان هذا المزحوم
لانه فيه مبيعات اعلى في ناس اكثر هذه هذه
من الممارسات اللي مثلا اتكلم عنها بشكل
او باخر بس يعني مش اللي انت تحتاجه هل
مثلا يشاركونكم العملاء وش الشيء اللي
سووه بيكون حل مرضي لاصحاب المطاعم
بالنسبه اقل
اليوم انت ما تقدر تقول نسبه اقل ابدا
يعني هو انا موقع معاه على النسبه هذي
وانا حتى يعني اقول الزملاء اصحاب المطاعم
يا اخي انت شايف انه هذه النسبه موجوده
قدامك
في اسعارك في التطبيقات احسب عندك نسبه
هذه تعطيها انا اتكلم انه لازم نموذج
العمل لازم السياسات لتتخذها التطبيقات
يجسوم مع اصحاب المطاعم
يصممونها بالشكل المناسب مثلا
اليوم انت تاخذ مني نسبه وتاخذ مني رقم
ثابت هذه الثنتين تلخبطني انا كصاحب مطعم
في الحسبه يعني انت تاخذ من اليوم 6000
ريال
اليوم اليوم
ترى جماعه ربحانين ههه
اوكي طيب
وتاخذ مني نسبه على المبيعات انا كصاحب
مطعم دفعت لك 6000 ريال بالعافيه عليك بس
اعطني اياها بالشكل اللي انا طلبته منك لا
تكفل علي خلني فوق منها القبيل بالنسبه
بالعافيه خذها طيب انت لما تعطيني رقم
ثابت ونسبه انا في حساباتي تطلع عندي
ملخبطه يعني مثلا انا
في التوصيل المخفف مين يدفع الفرق
طيب هذا عميلك
تبغى تعطيه توصيل مخفض ايش دخلني انا ادفع
عنه لا ولا ادفعها للتطبيق انا ادفعها
الشركه اللي توصل
طبعا هم ياخذونها مني بعدين توصل طيب هنا
في في لخبطه هنا نسبه وهنا رقم وهنا مبلغ
توصيل هذه كلها مثلا جاهز واشترك في
التوصيل مخفض ابو 9 ريال
بعدين يوم جتني الحواله منهم مثلا بعت
عندهم 100000
61 الف
وتندم خطا جاسم حاسب يحسب طلع معك اي خطا
هذي
للتطبيق اثنين ونصف في المئه للفيزا مع
انه كله اغلبه مدى مثلا على التطبيقات او
اس تي سي باي او غيره او معي بوابات
اكيد اقل طيب
اثنين ثلاثه في الميه اللي هي التعويضات
ثم مبلغ كبير اللي هي تغطيه توصيل المخفض
على حسابي
فوجدت اني دفعت له 39%
فترى برا يدفعون 25% 25% انا ادفع هنا 12%
39% عشان اشتركت التوصيل طيب بيقول لك ليش
تشترك انا اعطيتك عرض لا تشترك نرجع
للنقطه الاساسيه انه اصبح مهيمن علامه
مبيعات المطاعم انا اذا ما حطيت التوصيل
مخفض ما بعت
هو هو صمم كده التطبيق حقه انه العميل وجه
تلقائيا انه يروح للتوصيل مخفض
لاني مشترك عندهم بكون يعني بفكر اني ابغى
اربح لاني ابغى اخذ اللي توصل مجانا زي
كذا فاصبح سلوك العميل ما عاد يجي المطعم
هو يروح مثلا للبرايم
للتوصيل المخفض فانا ما عاد اظهر العميل
يعني ما مبيعاتي اساسا الا عن طريق
التطبيقات هذه كلها سلوكيات حقهم
والله يبارك لهم ورزقهم لكن لازم يكون فيه
يعني فهم لهذه الالام وحلها بسيط بس
الجماعه رافضين طيب هل نسبه المبيعات
الحين نتكلم عن ستين في المئه مثلا عن
طريق تطبيقات التوصيل هل هي اضافيه فاذا
هي اضافيه على مبيعاتك الاصليه يعني
فانا جبت لك ارقام انت ما كنت تصلها يعني
سياستي الشخصيه
في مطاعمي اني ما اشترك في التطبيقات في
البدايه
اول شيء انا افتح واحول زبوني انه يجيني
ويعرفني الناس اللي حوالي في الحاره من
القبيل الى نفس النقطه التعادل واتعداها
بعد ما تعدي نقطه التعادل ويصير عندي
مبيعات جيده اروح للتطبيقات لذلك مثلا
هناك يمكن ثاني شهر اشتركت في الجنوب ايضا
يمكن بعد سته شهور او ثمانيه شهور اشتركت
فسارت زي ما قلت بالفعل هذه اضافه خير
وبركه لذلك حتى المها علي انا عادي اي
واحد يبيع من مطعمه يسمونه من الناس اللي
يدخلون عندك فوق نقطه التعادل ترى اللي
يجي من التطبيقات خير وبركه اليوم لا
اليوم سلوك العميل انه 70% من مبيعاتي عن
طريق التطبيقات
الثلاثين في المئه اللي من المطعم ما تغطي
تكاليفي
فهنا يصير الالم اللي اليوم احنا نقول يا
ناس افهموا اللي كان في السابق كان كويس
بس هذاك ما عاد يصلح اليوم لهذا السبب
ممكن لو خلينا نشرع ما يتدخل وكانت تدخل
زي فكره كاري كيف تشوفها
بشكل كامل يعني فهمته لكن لازم تفهم كيف
الطرف الاخر يربح عشان تتاكد انه العلاقه
ستكون مستقره انا ما اعرف كيف بيرفع بيربح
كاني وفي اللقاء سمعته كامل ما افصح كيف
طريقه الربح قال هذا السر اخاف
ما ادري صراحه يعني هل هو بيكون شيء جيد
مناسب غير مناسب ما اعرفه يعني بسوي اذا
كانت فكره انه عارف ايش الالم الموجود وهو
يبغى يستغل هذه الفرصه لانه المطاعم
يصيرون معاه فممكن
حديث
نفسه احاديثه انه صراحه هو متفهم اكثر من
غيره
طيب وانا
متفاخ هذه الحلقه هذه الله يبارك فيك الله
يعطيك العيد والله شكرا لك شكرا جزيلا لك
الله يعطيك العافيه شكرا لكم شكرا لترك
القحطاني وعلى الحاجه في اعداد الحلقه
ومحمد نور الشمت في التحرير وهاب موسى في
التصوير وعبد المجيد عباس للتلوين محمد
الحسن في الهندسه الصوتيه وفي اداره محتوى
التواصل السبيعي واداره التحرير اللي
فنجان اسيل عبد الله هذا فنجان احد منتجات
شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع كل الانتاج
بحب من مدينه الرياض
الاسبوع المقبل القاكم
عند اسئله
[موسيقى]
جديده صارت في السوق
هذا مستر فتح 300 مطعم في ذيلها
[موسيقى]
يروح
المطاعم
طيب ويبيع عليهم الاسم
الوصفه خلني اروح لاي مطعم برضو حقتي
[موسيقى]
بس اخذ اسم عبد الرحمن اسمك يلا هذا بس
عنده قوه قوه ماليه
وعند قوه تسويقيه تعرف اظن الاكبر على
العالم الاقوى على المستوى العالم فهذه
الساده لكن هل يمكن تطبيقها
في كل مكان
والناس يبغون مبيعات اضافيه باي طريقه بس
يبغى لها الهه اعلاميه قويه يعني اما
مشاهير جروب مشاهير اكثر ناس ممكن ينجحون
في هذا اللي هم جروبات اليوتيوب حق
القيمرز لانه عندهم شعبيه كبيره مشاهدات
عاليه وكذا فاتوقع ينجح
الصيانه
في الصيانه وفي المساحه احسك تهتم
لاستغلال كل المساحات اللي عندك في المطعم
المفترض
بس انه في الاخير يعني لما تكون طاولات في
الاخير حطها اللي هي المساحات
تستغل مساحه يعني او مساحه ضخمه لانها
مساحات بهذا الشكل لو تحولات يعني وخصوصا
في تجربه شو اسمه
الناس تاكل وما عندهم مشكله رغم انه شعبي
قد يكون مبدا خاطئ عندي ما ادري والله لكن
انا اقول انه تجربه تجربه الناس اللي
ابغاها يعيشونها اللي هو انه يجلس على
الارض وجرب الاكل على الارض يعني انا اشعر
انه الشعبي ما ادري بس قدكم انه الجلسه
على الارض هذي والصحن قريب منك واضرب
بخمسين لا تاكل بملعقه ان الملاعق للاعمال
كفرانو انهم مهمه ههه
طيب بالنسبه للصيانه احس هذه من الاشياء
اللي دائما تزعجني يعني ادري انها بس يعني
مره مهتم للهويه جدا
كل التفاصيل بس يبدو لي
يعني انه عيد الاشياء خربت
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
الحمد لله
في خطا يعني في خطا من الناس صراحه لا لكن
ترى التشغيل عالي يعني
المغسله هذي يمر عليها في اليوم 150 شخص
200 شخص ولا ترى الخلل اللي يصير عندنا ما
ياخذ يمكن 24 ساعه بالكثير 48 ساعه وهو
معدل ونحاول نعدله بالشكل الجيد قدر
الامكان لكن تخيل يعني شهريا يدخل عندك
مثلا
معدل مثلا 200 شخص كبير وصغير اتكلم مع
6000 شخص
ففي استهلاك يعني عالي للمطعم
هذا هذا يمكن احد الاسباب ولا ابرر نفسي